Okay,
the Joe Rogan experience
Joe Rogan podcast by Katie Bowman.
Ladies and gentlemen,
move your DNA.
You could find her on twitter aligned
and.
Well she's friends with Rob Wolf,
so she must be cool.
And you're here.
What's up?
How are you?
I'm doing well.
Good.
I didn't want to talk to you too much
before the show because we were talking
about something that I'm very interested
in about how you live in Washington
state.
You found some clever area where it's in
Washington but it's not rainy every day
where you actually get sun.
That's true.
How'd you do that?
Magic.
You know,
I followed my family that someone else
found that magic and like how it always
happens.
I decided to go up there too.
And it's uh,
you can see like Vancouver and Vancouver
island right from where you're at.
Yeah.
I could row a boat to Canada if I had
to.
If the shit hit the fan shit,
hit the fan and I got my out.
Well that's what you started talking
about.
You started talking about like living
off the wild and,
and that's something that you're really
concerned with,
like are you a prepper?
I'm not,
I,
I'm not really concerned with it,
but it Kinda goes hand in hand with what
I teach about natural movements,
like I'm trying to put back these
isolated pieces of how you eat and how
you move and how you think and where you
spend your time and even where you spend
your money of going.
Well,
if we all just kind of go spend a little
bit more time out in,
in nature.
Um,
but I mean more than the park.
I mean,
I really mean wild.
You can see how it's been done for a
long period of time.
So trying to figure out how to get more
movement goes naturally with trying to
figure out how to acquire your own
foods.
So I thought,
well I'm a parent of two little kids.
I have a limited amount of time.
So what if our food acquisition is our
movement is our teaching,
our kids is our family,
time is everything and it's the same
hunk of time and we're just out there in
the wild.
I love it.
Then you're in an area that's
particularly like dense with wilderness,
with trees,
with animals and that whole area of the
Pacific northwest.
It's such a.
When you were talking about how you come
to California and everything's so dry,
it's almost like where's the life?
But if you go up there,
there's so much life.
It's ridiculous.
Well,
I went up there with my friend Duncan.
We were hunting for bigfoot,
was for a TV show and we went wandering
through the woods.
But the thing,
the soaps,
that's my computer isn't working.
The sound wasn't working up until then.
We got an issue with stream.
This is,
we have a totally new setup.
So we're an hd now.
So you look lovely in hd.
Um,
we were,
uh,
we,
we just got this new computer and this
whole jazz and we would maybe we should
just run the show for like a minute
before we go live.
That's what we'll do next time,
but uh,
anyway,
when we went up there,
like when you're wandering around
through the forest up there,
the thing that is so shocking is how
many animals there are and how much life
there as you see elk crap everywhere and
all these birds and rodents and just so
many,
so many,
so much variety of life up there
and that's the big stuff you can see
underneath every footprint.
There's like one or 200 organisms living
in every foot footprint that you take
there because it's just,
it's so deep.
It's just dense.
Dense is,
it's the densest place on the planet.
It is dense of,
of plant and animal stuffs.
Yeah.
And you don't have to worry about
drought up there.
Not this millennia.
Well,
not like we do here in California that
we need 11 trillion gallons of water
just to balance out what's been lost
over the last three years.
Yeah.
And even more,
even even more.
I guess alarming to me is less than the
total water,
but the amount of organization amongst
people it takes to get it here like
that.
I,
you know,
that's always what I was worried about
failing here.
Yeah,
the water supply,
the food supply,
the infrastructure,
the delivery system,
because none of it is actually here
like,
like I'm just thinking of something like
a power outage where so much of your
water is dependent on it being cleaned
and all of that is depends on energy
that requires a bunch of people.
Like my,
my in laws who live here in California,
their house has been without power for
two weeks and they live in an area north
of Orange County and they had to bring a
generator.
They put a generator into a neighborhood
because they're like,
well,
it's got to dig for it and frankly we
don't have the manpower right now.
And they're like,
when I started hearing stuff like that,
that's when I flee to the Pacific
northwest
so that there's an issue with their
lines.
The power lines are down or something
like that and so they have to dig for
the lines to put them back up.
So to live in like the camping
for two weeks,
camping in a very affluent area in
Orange County.
I mean this is like,
you know,
a nice neighborhood,
really nice neighborhood now where you
live,
do you have neighbors?
And we do want me to have two and a half
acres and,
but there are,
there are some neighbors,
you know,
but it's not um,
within the whole town,
the whole town's pretty small and you
can get to a place to see nobody,
you know,
within 10 minutes,
which I like.
Yeah,
that is nice if you want to get to
nobody in 10 minutes.
But I find that like when you're in
small towns and small areas,
the real issue is finding a cool small
town with a good sensibility,
a nice,
intelligent small town.
Because you can find some small towns,
like if you drive from southern
California up to northern California,
you can drive through some spots.
You have these giant Mitt Romney signs
that are still up.
And there's the weird religious signs
and these strange really sketchy
communities.
You're like,
oh boy,
you got a pretty view,
but fuck these neighbors.
Yeah,
it's a retirement community,
but you know,
you are where I am.
It's a retirement community because it
was a,
it used to be a,
um,
a logging town,
so it's,
it's got this waterway there,
it's next to some ports.
And so they've been moving with their
and milling it up and there's some paper
mills,
but a lot of that business has shut down
as people are buying stuff from
overseas.
And then of course as the wood is not
being able to be replenished as fast as
they'd been taking it down.
So I think in sunset magazine somebody
wrote an article about this town that
you could buy a few acres and,
and that it wasn't this what they call a
rain shadow.
So it's in the banana belt.
It's sunny almost every single day.
Totally different than any other place
in Oregon or Washington.
And you could buy an acre for it long
enough.
It was like $60,000
or $70,000.
So a whole bunch of people went out
there,
there's no,
there's no work or anything,
but they bought their homes and they
built them up,
but they're all kind of dying now.
The people,
the people who originally were there,
so,
so it's not that ideal,
small kind of funky ideal town yet.
But I decided,
well I can make that happen.
You were going to make sure I can do
that.
Like people in.
I'm not really about waiting around for
the ideal to happen.
I'll just build it from the ground up.
Sure,
yeah,
there you go.
And so,
um,
this area that you're at,
do you take your kids out fishing and
take them out gathering food and all
that jazz?
Yeah.
So it's huge.
A huge reservation land where we are.
So the salmon is unreal.
I live on the dungeness river,
so all the crap,
like all the crab that you met here from
Dungeness,
that's where it comes from.
So the,
the um,
the first nation peoples that lived
there,
the food was so abundant,
like that's all the things like,
um,
totem poles and big dugout canoes that
you see that came about because they
didn't have to really worry about food.
It's like listless of elk today.
Let's just sit here until one walks by,
wait till Baird's walks by,
you know,
the berries and the fruit and the wild
Greens and,
and then again the fish you could,
you know,
depending on the time of year,
just grab one out of the water,
you know,
if they're sponsors,
it's not hard to eat there.
So I thought,
what a great place.
There's so many elk up there.
I took a photograph of an elk standing
in front of a no hunting signs
close
because it was like,
right,
right when we were driving,
these elk were just wandering across the
road and they were just standing in
front of this no hunting.
So I'm like,
this is ridiculous.
That was the first elk I'd ever seen in
the wild to.
Those things are huge.
They're huge.
Yeah.
Like if you ever hit one with your car,
I
have not come close.
I've been waiting waiting for that to
happen.
They don't seem.
That bright.
Light seems smarter than a lot of
people.
I know.
Maybe that shows the area that you're
living with.
That's true.
They're cautious.
They're fleeting.
There's a little a herd of them that
lives in our town there,
that mascot of this little town,
and so there's a hurt and they've got
collars around their neck and we've got
elk flashing lights so you can their
colors because they just kind of.
Maybe they are dumb.
Maybe they just kind of stumbled across
the freeway every now and then,
so they flash up when they're close to
the highway.
The one on either side is they're moving
back and forth from the ocean,
so the gps collar collar that that the
government,
the local government is fitted them with
so that they can kind of track where
they're going to be in light the sign
up.
When the color comes close to these
signs,
you know,
that's where the elk are.
So you can sometimes look up and see the
whole herd sitting in the past year or
you know,
maybe walking across the freeway
seems weird.
I feel like I kind of liked the idea
that,
you know,
they know where they are,
but to put a collar on him and be able
to track them and seems like that's not
wild anymore.
Then you just roaming pet.
Yeah.
Maybe it will their mascots wildish
roaming mascots.
Wildish wildish eat them.
No.
I mean by whom?
No,
like hunting laws.
I don't.
I don't know if all of them are colored.
I think maybe just a couple of the males
are so then no,
you wouldn't be allowed.
Kenny them really can't shoot them.
I don't know.
They're not,
they're not really like hunting area.
They're like in these kind of like the
neighborhoods.
Maybe they're dumb.
Maybe they're totally.
You'd be amazed at some areas that you
can hunt in there.
Like a,
there's an area called Evergreen
Colorado and uh,
one of the issues that they have is the
local laws allow you to essentially hunt
in your backyard.
If you have more than x amount of land,
not much,
it's like two acres or something like
that.
I might be butchering this law,
but I remember there was some sort of a,
um,
an issue online when people debating it
because people were firing off guns and
their backyard,
like shooting it elk and deer and
they're like,
oh,
this is kind of fucked up.
Like we're not,
we're not really in the woods man.
Like my swing set is 100 yards to the
right.
So,
um,
but they have so many animals up there.
It's such a rich abundance of animals
and the people that rely on them for a
large part of their food,
you know,
moderate income or lower income
families,
if they get an elk,
like,
boy that is a year's worth of meat.
Like you've got a 1300 pound animal,
you're going to get 400 plus pounds of
meat from that.
That's 400 meals,
you know.
So for a lot of people that is literally
a year's worth of meat for your family.
So they'll just shoot that fucker right
in their backyard.
Yep.
Everybody's got a duck for a couple
minutes and come on over.
I'll give you a ham.
The salmon fishing up there must be
amazing.
Amazing,
Actually,
when does the weirdest going down?
You know,
they,
there was a dam up there for a really
long time,
like 100 years that they've just taken
down.
You can actually watch the
deconstruction of this dam a couple of
years
and we were walking around at the bottom
of what has been,
you know,
this damned up body of,
of water and some friends of ours were
biologist took us upstream because
they're there,
they're doing a lot of salmon
restoration,
you know,
they're trying to get everything back to
what it was a couple of hundred years
ago because it's very different because
of this dam.
And he is our friend Keith.
He just reached down and he picked up
the salmon like right out of the water,
this huge thing.
I mean the thing was a foot and a half
more.
It was 15 pounds and he just picked it
right up and he was like,
here's where the eggs are.
And then he.
Then it turned out to be a male and he
just grabbed it and he just shot all of
the salmon.
Salmon is also the river because they're
spawning and he just,
he just deals with salmon all day long.
It was amazing.
Was opponent out of a weird,
like a salmon?
We're.
Or was he pulling out of the river was
retarded because they're spawning so
when they're spawning they just rub up
against anything.
Well they're just,
when they're spawning,
you know,
they're trying to get to kind of shallow
water.
So a lot of them are kind of,
you know,
they have to make it up through the
river even as the river changes in terms
of volumes.
So where it's a little low,
they just kind of walk up.
It kind of take themselves out of the
water.
They're,
they're amazing.
Well,
I mean I've seen bears pulled them out
on tv,
like in deeper waters because they're
jumping.
These ones are actually on the ground,
but they're just wiggling.
Yeah.
So he said the females will be way more
scratched up.
You can tell during spawning season a
male versus a female because the female
is just really desperately trying to get
her eggs to someplace.
And I guess the male just drop his load
kind of wherever he's less intense about
it.
Goofy designed by nature,
Huh?
Yeah.
Or,
or just amazing like in what I find
interesting is so salmon that they're
raising in,
um,
whatever they call it,
like in the fisheries,
you know,
in the hatcheries,
the identify them because they remove
what they will call like a vestibular
Finn.
This,
I think it's called an adipose Finn.
Um,
so that they can recognize which ones
are wild in which ones are introduced.
But,
but um,
and I was talking to some biologists in
part of a lot of stuff that I do is,
is kind of redefining what's actually
this digital era and what's just,
we don't know what it is,
so it must not be necessary anymore.
And he said,
well,
it's interesting because he was
explaining it's kind of like the
appendix of the fish.
It's not really necessary.
And I was like,
well,
it turns out that our appendix isn't
really as digital as it was once
thought,
you know,
it's a little bit more necessary.
And it is.
Yeah,
it's not,
it has a role whether that role is
challenged by modern living,
that's really more where,
what the issue is.
If it still is,
it still is harboring.
I can't remember exactly what it is.
It's harboring some sort of bacteria
depending on the exposure.
You have two different foodstuffs and
I'll
have to look it up a little bit more.
But.
But he said it's interesting that you
say that because they're wondering why
these fish don't do really,
really well.
So perhaps it's because they're removing
the fin and as I did a little bit more
research on that fin that Finn in
particular deals with assisting swimming
through very particular types of
turbulence.
And so it,
it is,
it's not something that you use 100
percent of the time,
but it's used over the lifetime of a
salmon.
Just put like a tag on that thing
instead of dragging it off.
Too much drag.
I don't know.
I don't know,
there's so many problems to solve and so
little time,
well,
so many problems to solve when your
people and you want to fuck with
animals,
want to cut their fins off and put
collars on their elk in this area that
you live in.
Sounds like ideally it sounds beautiful.
It is.
And does this have anything to do with
what you do for a living?
Does it have anything to do with what
you're all about?
Movement and alignment and
like I'm all about natural movement and
an alignment being a component of that,
but I would say that the reason we moved
up there as we were just unable to
execute our life the way with we wanted
here,
like there was,
there's a,
there's a physical blockage to moving in
the way that we need to move and I was
like,
well the only way to remove that
blockage is to take ourselves away from
the environment that's limiting this,
this way of moving,
which is,
which is larger than it sounds.
It's not like,
you know,
make sure you get these seven exercises
into your workout.
It's,
it's,
it's very broad and it has to do with
the loads that your body experiences and
then that goes for light and noise and
all the different ways your cells are
deformed by your habitat.
So if,
when you talk about,
when I talk about movement,
I really like in the way that we move to
be similar to animals that are in zoos.
Like if you ever go to a zoo and check
out that kind of unfortunate thing,
you'll see these animals and they have
movement,
you know,
they have,
yeah,
cages or habitats designed for them,
but the way that they used them is
pretty narrow and it goes for us as
well.
So that's,
that's,
that's why the move.
I just wanted less people,
more space,
less rules,
less noise,
more water.
Yeah.
And when you say like we're being
deformed or like in what way?
Well in the book,
the analogy that I use,
because I think it's easiest to
understand is if you look at workers in
a place like sea world,
have you seen their folded over fin?
That's the kind of defamation that I'm
talking about.
I'm talking about like um,
you are shaped really by the forces that
you experience all the time.
Your mechanical environment is 100
percent of the time and so the resultant
shape of your body
is based on this exposure in the same
way that the Orca was missing input,
it was missing mechanical input and it
was exposed to high levels of mechanical
input that gets this result in shape,
you know,
in,
in the difference between what the Orca
is.
When you look at an Orca,
it's like clearly it's not supposed to
be at seaworld and clearly that shaped
doesn't seem conducive to swimming,
you know,
at least in a straight line.
So we don't see that in ourselves very
well though because we are the Orca in
the tank and everyone else is in the
tank with us.
So it's really hard to see how you would
have been shaped and it's really hard to
imagine what the resultant shape of us
would be culturally if,
if there were more examples of people
who moved in drastically different ways,
which there are not.
Well,
I know posture is a big issue with
Americans.
It's a big issue with anybody in all
parts of the world that have to sit at
desks all the time.
You know,
the expression sitting is the new
smoking.
We've tried really hard in this place to
change that up.
We've got these desks or these chairs
from Ergo depot.
These are called Cup Pisco.
I had a couple different ones before I
started off with regular chairs like
that,
but by the end of the podcast,
my back,
I've had some back issues with Jujitsu.
I had a bulging disc at one point,
my cervical spine and that's all healed
up now,
but if I sit in something like that and
I kind of have that hunch thing that you
get from a chair by the end of the show,
I'll just get stiff in my back.
But with these things,
nothing.
So something that forces you to sit
erect,
you realize like how few of us actually
do that and how many people are like
have that weird hunch spine thing going
on,
which constantly puts pressure on your
spine and I never thought anything of
that until I started doing this fucking
podcast and I'm like sitting down all
the time,
all day.
And it just,
it really puts into perspective how many
people are doing it.
Not Me for three hours a day.
They're doing eight,
nine,
10 hours a day even more staring at
computers all day.
Everyone's going blind early.
Right?
You know,
I'm uh,
my,
my vision sucks.
It used to be really good,
but now I need,
I need reading glasses to read stuff
that's close up and I know it has
something to do with age,
but it definitely has something to do
with staring at monitors too.
It's just not good for you.
No.
And it's the distance,
you know.
Um,
I,
I tried to talk about casts,
casts,
casts.
When you break your arm,
those are really easy to see.
There's like a physical structure that
you can't move your arm.
It's really harder to see these
invisible casts so distance the distance
of something from your eye is a cast
upon the Lens,
so when you look at something,
what allows you to focus on that is that
the distance that you're looking at,
your,
your mind,
your musculature of the.
I will change the shape of your lens so
that that distance is what you're
looking at.
When you want to see something farther,
you look up and you look at it and then
these muscles,
these ciliary muscles in the eye will
change the shape of the eye and allow
you to focus that to that distance.
But humans,
modern humans in the places where we
live very rarely look beyond 20 feet.
I mean you're not looking at anything.
I mean,
so like you can say that it's the screen
because the screen is two feet away and
there's certainly a much greater
frequency of screen use.
Like by the time you look at your ipod
or your iphone and you're looking at
your computer and doing whatever work
that's on that,
that number has gone up.
But what's always been high is that you
don't see much beyond the walls of your
house.
So that's another reason you don't have
the ability to look very far indoors,
does not allow you to look very far.
And so right now with that vision,
with kind of understanding like why is
Myopia,
which is that near sightedness coming up
with such great frequency years to be
one kid in school with glasses,
right?
And now there are seven or eight,
you got one third of the classroom who
can't see at ages six and seven kids are
starting now to be put in glasses like
in four and five years old because
they've been looking.
They don't even have outdoor playtime,
you know,
they're not even going outside.
And so they know that outdoor time is a
factor in those and have less myopia.
So then they're trying to test it like,
is it the near work?
And I,
I wrote a piece about this that there's
a difference between going outside.
So they're like,
is it the vitamin D?
Is it the light exposure?
But they were able to figure out by
isolation that it wasn't that,
and so then I.
my contribution is,
well,
what about distance looking?
That distance looking itself is a
different variable in something that you
don't.
It's not a load to the eye that we're,
I'm very experienced with.
But if you had to again go out and get
your food and you were moving around,
it's not just that you're outside more.
It's a.
You need to be able to see things kind
of far away.
If you've ever gone hunting.
Hunting is,
especially if we're doing like spot and
stock type hunting,
being able to look at long distances and
seeing and spotting animals,
you know,
before you make your way over there,
that's a skill to be able to look 30 or
40 or 60 feet to the top of a tree to
kind of see what's up in there.
That's just a.
it's a part of your workout that you're
missing,
so to speak.
You're not cross training your eyes with
enough types of exercises.
You do two feet and you do however far
your television is,
and then maybe the.
The bumper of the car in front of you,
I mean we're not distance lookers at all
anymore,
so have ophthalmologists and
optometrists have,
they've sort of just accepted the fact
that people,
their eyes are just going to go bad
because this is the environment we live
in.
So this is just an inevitable fact of
aging.
And is that something that can be
avoided by spending a lot of time
outdoors,
looking at long distance stuff and
looking at things that are 100 yards
away,
500 yards away and focusing your,
your vision on those things?
Yeah.
Well I don't,
I don't think they want you to accept
it.
It's not.
I mean it's not an inevitable thing.
That's why they're working on the
literature for it.
So the actual researchers in eyes are
trying to find like what it is,
do we need more supplementation?
But they're like,
kids really
do need to be outside a lot more.
Um,
because the shape of the size of your
eye is changing.
And so when the eye freezes or as cast
by something near and then your eyes
start growing,
but the lens has to stay the same size,
then you have this mismatch between the
size of your eye and the Lens.
And so that's why this childhood myopia
kind of starts moving with you into
adulthood and you become an adult that
needs glasses.
So.
So yes,
they are calling for that intervention.
And then there's a lot of I exercise
programs,
you know,
people trying to create some sort of
corrective.
My recommendation is you got to get
yourself near a window if you're an
office worker and you have to just take
an eyebrow,
you need to look as far away as possible
just to.
It's like if you did a bunch of curls,
bicep curls,
and you never ever put your arm down,
it's like you did them all.
And then when you were done,
you tied it up there.
You can imagine what the shape of the
bicep would look like and the function
of the elbow and the shoulder and how
eventually that bicep would not just
pull your lower arm up to your upper
arm,
but would start to pull your shoulder in
towards your upper arm.
Same thing goes with the eyes,
you know,
first the muscles that move the shape of
the Lens,
do that,
but then the tighter they are,
the more they begin to pull the whole
structure of the eyeball down itself.
And then you're starting to look at,
well,
how does that affect the pressure of the
eye?
And in,
in so many things that occur in the body
are,
um,
mechanically sensitive.
You know,
you,
all your pressures are depend on all
your pressures everywhere else.
And when you start to forming the shape
of structures,
it does start effecting those functions
that are positioned dependent,
which is almost all of them
sort of like when people were a wallet
in their pockets,
bulging discs.
That's a really common thing with folks.
Have you,
you don't know if you have a wallet and
you put it in your back pocket,
please stop doing it.
Um,
I recently,
I used to get mocked because I had a
wallet chain because I lost my wallet
twice.
Okay.
Relax people.
Plus they look kind of sweet.
But uh,
I got this wallet recently.
It's a front pocket wallet,
just keeps a few credit cards and my
driver's license and that's it.
I went and minimalist and ever since I
did that I just,
I'm aware that I can just sit down and
have to pull it because I would always
take my wallet out of my pocket and then
sit down,
which is one of the reasons why I wanted
it attached to a chain because I'm
absentminded,
but people that have these big fat
wallet,
everybody gives you a business card all.
Let me just stick that in there.
You're sitting on a brick,
you know,
you're sitting on an encyclopedia,
stuff that sucker into your pocket and
you've got this weird angle that you're
at all the time.
You're always sitting in a weird lump
and soft tissue is very pliable and
that's something that.
It's also something that really
frustrated me about getting a back
injury was how many people were like,
well,
you're going to have to get surgery,
and I was like,
oh,
what the fuck?
Like there's no way to fix this.
There's no way to stretch this out.
There's no way to.
It's compressed,
right?
Have suffered Capri.
Is there a way to decompress it?
And then I went to other people and
like,
yeah,
of course we do decompression therapy.
Like,
okay,
well what the fuck?
Well,
how come this doctor is telling me that
you got to cut my back,
and then there's.
Have you ever heard of the reverse hyper
machine?
Yes.
Louie Simmons,
this guy from west side barbell in
Columbus,
Ohio,
created this amazing machine that I have
in the back now that I use almost every
day.
It's fantastic because it offers
decompression and this incredible
strengthening of the back.
It's this amazing machine that as you
you're lifting up your.
You're flexing your back and is very
unusual way that it's really hard to
work out any other way and then on the
release it's actually actively
decompressing your spine,
so it's because of guys like him.
Louis Siemens is powerlifter genius,
sort of bio mechanic dude who figured
out he had an injury and they wanted a
fuses discs and he was like,
fuck that,
you know,
let me let me figure out a way around
this,
and he figured out a way and he fixed it
and he fixed it through this.
Just using what he knows about exercise
and the mechanics of the body and coming
up with some sort of machine that would
allow the decompression of that soft
tissue and that's something that I think
we all have to be aware of when it comes
to posture.
Posture is a giant one with people.
I had terrible posture like most of my
life until I started getting back issues
and one of the things that I realized is
even though I was healthy and strong,
I was able to avoid a lot of pain that
was associated with that bad posture.
The bad posture was still screwing me up
and like just being able to sit up
straight.
It just feels odd when you do it,
but if you do it and like you force
your,
it's like an active exercise.
You force yourself to do it,
you want a slump because it's like you
feel like you're using less energy but
you're really screwing your body up when
you do it
and you're using less energy.
Yeah.
Which is,
which is fine in some cases.
I mean using less energy is good in some
cases,
but I think it has has less to do with
like with good posture,
but the thing with the thing with
posture,
his posture is this modern construct
that has arisen in a culture that
doesn't move at all.
Right?
So it's really like what's the optimal
way to be still because that's the wrong
question or asking kind of the wrong
question.
Yes.
That's the first question.
The first question is to assume that
there is nothing you can change about
your life,
that you can't move to a wonderful place
in,
cultivate a wonderful city to live in,
but right now if you feel stuck in your
job,
the tendency is to make that environment
better,
but I always like to point out that
posture isn't something that you would
be as concerned about if you were moving
a lot more in general that the resting
tensions of your body would be doing all
the things that you know,
we're trying to do in small blips on,
on different machines,
in posture classes.
You know,
in posture books.
They just got to move more to.
And also even standing up though,
even if you are moving,
like there's a lot of people that move
and they of have that hunch for thing
going on and even if you're out there
doing stuff like especially like when
you're exercising you,
you put a tremendous amount of pressure
on your back and really weird ways if
you don't use proper posture like with
squats and things along those lines.
It's so super important.
Yeah.
Forum forum is huge during your workout
and all the other times too.
Yeah,
and form for everything,
not just for lifting weights for martial
arts,
of course,
this gigantic,
you know,
doing things correctly.
If you do things incorrectly,
you put a lot of load on weird areas of
your joints and your hips and your back.
And so many people want to be healthier.
So many people want to be.
They wanted to get out of this Rut
they're in and,
and get there.
But it seems like the,
just a modern life that most people are
either found themselves in by
circumstance by lack of understanding,
but whatever it is you find yourself in
this,
this way or this way of life,
which it almost makes it
incomprehensibly difficult to like be
healthy,
to be fit,
to be,
to have a body that functions correctly.
If you're sitting in a desk all day,
like what are the things that people
should be concentrating on if they find
themselves stuck in a work environment,
you're in a cubicle.
Like is there a way to mitigate that?
There is.
Um,
I think one of the things that I've
known for most is that thinking,
if you think about in terms of like your
exercise,
a lot of people will try to figure out
like,
healthy to them as what are you doing
for exercise?
What are you eating for your diet?
So you're,
you're,
you're trying to maximize those two
categories,
but um,
you've got all of this other time in
which you are getting your work done and
you can make that healthier too.
So like we know you were talking about
your wallet for example,
when I was thinking,
you know,
you put this big hunk under one hip and
so you take it out.
Well a lot of people put two big hunks
of wallet,
dish type stuff under their feet every
single day.
And they call them shoes.
You know,
they'll put like a big,
big wedge about high heels.
I'm talking about trainers,
you know,
like your athletic shoe could have an
inch and a quarter is standard,
a man's dress shoes almost two full
inches.
We'd,
it's not sin in spiky and Fashiony,
but,
but that is the equivalent to the
wallet.
It's just because it's symmetrical.
We think of,
well,
it's symmetrical,
like the thing,
your wallet under your hip.
It's not just that it's asymmetrical.
If you had a wallet in each hip,
either the problems of having something
underneath under that soft tissue would
still be there.
It would just.
It would be more subtle.
You wouldn't have this big torque there
as well.
It would just be kind of continuous
pressure,
but people put stuff on their feet every
single day that affects every other
joint north of their ankle.
And then you compensate all day long
your whole entire life you've been
compensating.
And over time you lose.
You lose parts to your body.
You lose little.
The little contract
components that make up muscle,
like the sarcomeres that make up your
muscle length.
Those just go away.
You cannibalize those,
um,
which means you lose range of motion,
which means even when you go to move
your parts during this part of your life
that you've set aside to move,
which is different than the rest of your
life that you've set aside to not move.
You're moving less,
you're moving less of you.
So that's,
that's always a huge one.
Like what if I told you your whole body
would work better if you fix what you
were putting on your feet everyday,
you're just going to put shoes on any
way,
like what does it matter what they are?
If you could put on a pair of shoes that
allowed your whole body to function in a
different way,
it would be the equivalent to saying,
I got this new workout,
like this new cross training piece.
Your workout is stale,
you're not as strong as you should be,
or that you'd like to be.
For the thing that you're doing that you
can introduce whole new load spectrum to
your body just by changing your shoes
would have.
What do you think about those?
What are they called?
Mbts?
Is that what it was called?
The barefoot technology.
The rocker bottom ones.
What are the.
What's the deal with those?
Those stupid.
Well,
there are a rocking chair for your feet,
so if you want it,
like if you ever sit down in a rocking
chair,
that's called momentum and that's not
something you want in your gait pattern.
You don't want your shoes to be throwing
you forwards that you don't have to
expend as much energy to do it,
that you balance yourself constantly on
those things and in doing that you're
using all those little muscle groups.
Is that all bs?
I don't know if it's all BS.
It's just.
It doesn't get.
Its mostly bs.
Mbs isn't there?
Almost called MTS mpt.
It's just this bigger like I don't know.
I always think a lot larger than that.
I'm thinking about like there is a
cellular environment,
there is a nutritious movement,
like it's the equivalent to nutritious
food is that there is a way to move that
as nutritious to your body and you're
missing some huge nutrients so you
should wear flat shoes all the time.
Flexible,
flexible.
There's a little bit of a bottom to
that.
There's more on the.
If you grab him,
if he grabbed them and bend them over,
what do they do?
Like here's my shoes,
flip flops.
That's it.
Yeah,
but also,
but decidedly not flip flops because if
you put,
if it's just flip flops then you have to
grab to hold them and then you've got
all this tension and your foot and your
gait patterns all messed up from,
from natural,
just to hold on the thing on your foot.
So it's kind of like your,
your movement is very reflexive,
you know,
you are an animal,
you're a primate and in your movements
should be much more reflective than it's
happening right now.
And in one of the reasons that makes it
so difficult is because of all of these
casts,
these,
these things that we put on everything.
It's fascinating that you refer to like
a cast for your eyes because I never
thought about it that way,
but as soon as you said,
I was like,
oh,
that totally makes sense.
Like your house is kind of a cast is a
cast,
the cast being in a work environment,
an office as a cast,
not looking at things for large
distances.
That is a cast.
Um,
the,
the shoe thing I wear converse all stars
most of the time because of that,
because they're flat and they're really
flexible and light.
Those are okay.
Those,
those would be helpful.
Can you spread your toes out wide but
then there's this whole other level.
Why is that important?
There's muscles in their 25 percent of
the number in your muscles.
In your body or from your ankle down.
Maybe you.
Maybe not me.
No,
you might have more muscles.
Not Muscle mass.
Muscle mass.
I'm just talking shit.
What about those toe shoes?
Toe Shoes.
I liked the toe shoes.
You get a little bit more for that,
but you have to,
you have to transition pretty hard.
It's like you've been wearing cast,
like if you broke your arm you wouldn't
cut it off and then start doing
cartwheels and stuff.
Why do all my workouts barefoot?
That's great.
I do all my weightlifting barefoot.
All my martial arts stuff is off course
barefoot.
But uh,
like sometimes I'll take pictures of a
gym workouts and like,
what are you doing barefoot?
Man,
you crazy going to drop things on your
feet.
I guess what,
man,
you drop things in your feet normally
you're fucked anyway.
If you're lifting 400 pounds,
if you have shoes on,
you're still fucked.
It's gonna.
Smush your toes.
Just don't drop things on your feet.
Dummy.
How often do you drop things on your
feet?
I don't drop things on my feet.
I pay attention.
Well,
that's the thing.
If,
if,
if you go barefoot,
you learn how to pay a lot of attention.
Yeah,
little kids,
man.
My Kid's stomped on my feet all the
time.
I'm barefoot around the house and they
love it.
They think it's funny,
but I'm.
While I'm teaching my six year old
daughter a teacher,
kickboxing and so now she thinks it's
funny to just run up on me and leg
kicked me and it's starting to get hard.
Like she's six and she's.
She knows how to whip her body into it.
Now she's a little athlete.
She knows how to turn your hips because
I've taught her like how to really
generate force.
So the other day she came up to me and
she did this like perfect pivot and
whack and just dug one right into my
calf.
I was like,
oh,
you little fucker.
Like it was good.
It was good.
I was proud of how it's pretty good.
But I didn't see it coming.
You know,
they just,
they,
well when there's six they feel like
you're invulnerable.
So they just tee off on you whenever
they want,
you know,
we can't let them know.
But I mean it doesn't really hurt yet
but it's like,
hey you gotta we've got about four more
years of that before we're going to have
an issue.
When she gets to like 13,
14,
you could really hurt somebody.
So don't only do it to me.
We have like rules in our house.
We're only allowed to hit daddy and you
know,
he can't hit each other but you could
hit daddy.
And so we,
we play just by.
I just feel like the best way to teach
the martial arts is to show them the
techniques,
but then actually have them hit a person
because you can hit punching bags and
stuff all you want,
but I want them to like specifically
target areas like this is the area
supposed to hit I.
This is why you're supposed to hit this
area.
So I let him hit me like a lot of
barefoot stuff.
Point is.
Yeah,
and a lot of people don't.
Don't do anything barefoot.
So if you're doing,
you know the bulk of your movement with
barefoot,
that's great,
but you could also do your podcast
barefoot.
Really?
Why would that help?
Why does it help your workout?
But I'm moving my feet around.
I'm sitting here will move around.
I would suggest that you move around
more to like wiggle my toes around.
People are weird.
They're sitting around barefoot somehow
or another would with girls.
It doesn't bother me,
but like if I'm sitting like Eddie
Bravo,
I love Eddie.
Bravo two dads is a good buddy of mine.
That dude's always barefoot.
It was playing with his feet and stuff
like,
come on,
man,
puts his feet up on tables in a
restaurant and just.
He's always stretching.
He's super.
He's a Jujitsu master,
so he was always like,
got one foot here and one foot here is
always pushing his weight down,
stretching himself.
He's always barefoot.
That's why he's a master maybe.
Yeah.
Wow.
Was that the 10,000
hours thing?
You know,
it's got a lot of years of choking
people and thinking about it too,
but the.
He's always barefoot like so.
There's probably something to that and
he lifts weights,
will converse all stars of the gym.
They don't let you lift weights at a gym
gym most of the time,
barefoot,
but those toe shoes didn't.
Wasn't really a class action lawsuit
that said those toe shoes were bullshit.
No.
The class action lawsuit was that the
woman who brought about the class action
said that the advertising imply that all
you had to do was buy the shoes that you
didn't.
You didn't have to figure out how to use
your body differently,
so it had nothing to do with how they.
How they performed it was about their,
their claim,
so the way she interpreted it was that
she just had to put them on her feet and
that she would be healthier and have
less injuries.
Marika,
let's
mark.
Yeah,
Jesus Christ.
These class action lawsuits,
some of them are just so God damn goofy.
You let go.
Come on.
Really.
You thought you could put shoes on and
you would become a super person.
Might have.
It's true though,
but that's the real issue.
If they do one day come up with
something that you just put it on and
makes you a way better athlete.
Like then what's the point of being?
Yeah,
it's like steroid shoes,
you know,
like all of a sudden people are running
faster.
She didn't that um,
the,
the South African guy who shot his
girlfriend the,
what's his name?
The guy with the blades.
Pistorius.
Yeah.
That guy.
Those blades,
like a lot of people feel like they can,
you can actually run faster with those
things on because they offer some sort
of a spring that you could with just
your regular feet.
So they get to that with shoes.
Then we've got an issue.
People,
do you think people will be taking their
own feet off just to get those too?
When we've actually discussed that,
what we've discussed is not for those
blades,
but there's gonna come a time where
there was a guy that we,
um,
we talked about on the podcast once he
had gotten his leg and his arm bitten
off by a shark and he had replaced them
with these really high tech replacement
hands that articulate and his,
his leg was perfectly suited to his body
and he walked around with no limp.
It was so strange and you see the guys
there talking and he's having a
conversation and talking about that and
he's using his,
his,
his artificial hand and his real to
gesture and like,
well,
what,
what they're going to get better at
those.
Like the old days it was like I went to
school with this girl and she lost her
arm like really early on in life.
And it was always,
you know,
everybody was always weirded out by it.
She had a hook.
It's a very nice girl,
but she was like,
if she had like this artificial hand
that looked exactly like a real hand is
just a different color.
Well,
what,
how much different would people react to
her then a decade later if she has an
artificial hand that has some sort of an
artificial skin component to it that
actually has sensitivity built into it,
that it interacts with her nerves that
allows.
I mean,
they have some that allow you to pick up
pieces of glass and not break them.
I mean they have like,
really?
They,
they allow you to feel pressure,
like really sensitive one.
So they're developing one day they're
going to get one that's better than your
actual legs.
So if you had these regular legs,
we can give you an operation and uh,
it'll make you run like Hussein bolt.
You're going to have some artificial
legs,
you know,
it's going to,
going to go through a rehab process.
You won't be able to walk for a couple
of weeks because we're going to cut your
fucking legs off and stuff.
These carbon fiber jammies in there and
and put the joint endings in and fuse
them with this new thing that we've
created.
Yeah,
someone's going to do that.
Totally.
Absolutely.
It's just a matter of time.
Just a matter of time before we have
artificial bodies into someone's going
to just suck your head right out of your
brain,
right out of your head and stuffing into
this thing and boom,
you're just going to be like piloting
around this crazy body right now.
You think.
I absolutely think that that's kind of
beyond the point though,
right?
Until then we've got to deal with what
we have.
Well,
yeah.
Well I would say,
I mean I'm,
I'm a biomechanist,
so a lot of the colleagues that I work
with are in a orthopedic development and
stuff that you're talking about,
so it's kind of my,
my territory just to see what people are
coming up with,
but the big thing that you can't really
get around yet is that,
that your,
that your parts are doing other parts
and just moving you around.
That's always kind of the limitation of
like if you,
if you lose a part,
you know that's,
that's the loss and you can replace it,
but to voluntarily take off healthy
parts,
those parts do things other than just be
those parts.
They're,
they're participating in the system.
It's like kind of the same thing,
like you can't take an animal out of an
ecosystem because the,
all the other animals collapse without
it because they're expanding out of
control and something else is dying off.
It's the,
it's the same thing.
The parts,
the part has a role as a part,
but it also has a role within the system
and so that'll be the backfiring on
that.
The balance though,
just like putting an invasive species
into an ecosystem,
screws everything up.
There's a balance.
There's a relationship between
everything else.
It took a really long time to establish
and when you start messing around that
around,
you're playing clean up like the rest of
your life.
Yeah.
Now when you like,
when you think about human movement,
like what?
Besides the shoes that you wear,
what are the other big issues that
people have and how
they,
how they get through this life with
their body?
Well,
people don't walk enough like they're
missing in.
Like there's a whole group of people who
don't eat any fat.
A lot of people don't eat any fat as a
whole category of a,
a micronutrient and then they're slowly
introducing it back in and they're like,
I had all these health problems because
I was missing I'm fat.
Or maybe I didn't eat any protein or
maybe I didn't eat any animal products.
You know,
like they've got these big voids in
their diet and then there are diseases
that show up when you have some,
some void like vitamin C,
no one even knew you needed vitamin C
until you have this group of sailors,
you know,
in this case population that went
without it.
And it's like,
well,
they have that.
They had adequate food so it's not
calories they're missing.
And it took 40 years before someone
realize it.
The vitamin C it's APP.
We've figured out that we can get them
their connective tissue to stop bleeding
profusely if we give them a oranges or
lemons,
and then it took another 60 or 70 years
for someone to identify that as vitamin
C.
it's like it's essential.
Your body can't live without it,
and so,
so walking is really one of those things
that your body can't.
They can't function as it as it should
without it that,
that there are these other byproducts
that go along when you walk in a
particular way,
so that's where alignment comes in,
that there's this,
these series of loads that are created
by using your body and in walking would
have been the thing that you would be
doing most often out of out of all the
moves that your body has done for the
millennium,
walking is the load maker that you would
do the most and there's people who just
don't walk at all.
They work out,
they're fit,
they run,
they do everything,
but they don't walk.
That's huge.
So just walking alone,
just important just to to balance out
your body,
just to be a normal,
healthy person.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a,
it's an input,
it's an input to your,
to your body slam.
We don't think of movement as an input,
but it's a squash,
like your cells are squashed by the way
that you move and then then the way that
the cells expressed themselves,
they're kind of,
their genetic expression is,
is comes about by the mechanical
environment is one of the important
environments.
And,
and right now for a lot of people it's
walking free.
So just walking,
it doesn't really have any purpose in
our life any longer because you don't,
you don't have to walk anywhere to get
anything done.
But,
but like this Orca Fin,
you know,
the way,
the way that an Orca swims in the wild
is what maintains its structure.
There's nothing that the Orca can do now
with this flopped over fin.
It can't,
it can't do opposing fin curls.
It can't foam roller out the floppy
side.
The structure has been set by the fact
that swims in a circle.
So it softens all,
all,
uh,
fins soften as the worker goes from it's
juvenile through its teenager to
adulthood.
But coupled package with that is
swimming in a particular way at depths
where the forces are such that it
maintains and shapes this structure,
this end result that we call an Orca.
So we're,
we are swimming metaphorically,
just counterclockwise all of the time.
And so our structure,
our definition of fit and healthy is
like the peak of that.
This orca with the flopped over fin,
whatever.
Get swimming in a circle at seaworld and
you can see the vast difference between
any possible swimming program he can be
put on there compared to how he would
swim in the ocean,
getting food every day,
which is like 100 miles of swimming
every day.
Fast sprints when they have to get
something,
you know,
there's,
there's mating their social time,
there's all these things that go on in
the wild that is the necessary input for
being an Orca.
And then you just say,
well then what,
what necessary inputs are we missing?
Kind of is as humans because so much of
our physiology depends on how we move
and how we don't.
So,
uh,
to use an analogy that you used earlier,
like the Orca in that pool is kind of in
a cast,
correct?
Because the atrophy of lawyer,
I had my arm broke once and I had a cast
when I took my arm out of the cast,
it was like this little shriveled up
thing,
you know,
and everybody knows that when you don't
use your muscles,
they just decide,
oh,
we don't need these and they shrink
down.
And so that's what's happening to this,
this poor things thin
and,
and everyone that,
you know,
even even people that you know who have
a ton of muscle mass,
it's just compare the distribution of
muscle mass that you see is just
compared to people who don't do those
particular things that you do to get
that muscle mass.
But there is a whole other mass
distribution that would come about were
you to do other things.
And so I'm,
I'm mostly concerned with disease.
What I,
what I work on most are human diseases
and,
and basic human functions.
What I'm most interested in is,
um,
she'll like,
uh,
getting pregnant,
maintaining your delivery and then
delivering this child like that.
We're having some serious fertility and
delivery problems,
which are,
you know,
like the level one for a species,
like the survival of a species is like,
what do you mean people can't get
pregnant or they can't birth third
children anymore.
Like they need special equipment and
medical intervention.
Like these are big signs for a species
that it.
Same thing happens in zoos,
right?
Like animals don't breed well in zoos
because they are missing things.
And so it's the same thing that we're
experienced.
That's an interesting way of putting it.
Animals don't breed well in zoos because
they're missing.
Their environment has been radically
changed.
And that's the same thing with people.
Well,
they're supposed to be interacting with
other animals.
I mean like there's so much.
There's isolation,
not,
not just the animal itself from its herd
or it's try,
but then from other animals.
Again,
this is a big system and in zoo research
is really interesting because it's
covering everything.
Like what happens when you put a zoo in
a city,
you know,
and,
and have light,
you've got light going on all of the
time.
So,
um,
there's,
there's constant what they call night
lighting,
so light beyond this,
the sun.
And then there's metal noises,
the loud clanging.
Plus there's all these biological cues
that if you ever go camping,
you know,
you hear the bugs,
the bugs let you know the birds let you
know where everything else is in that
there are cultures who understand who,
who have this input of,
of noise.
And from a scientific perspective,
you know,
there's like these things.
All of the data that we have on humans
really comes from the last,
oh,
maybe like 60 to 100 years.
And so there's like these basic in
psychology tests,
like you've probably seen them where
they've got the arrows,
the outset arrows pointed outward on the
tips.
And then on the other tip of the other
early point in words,
which line is longer,
it's kind of an optical illusion and you
get it wrong.
Like everyone says that the arrows that
point in his longer or whatever,
and it was like,
so this is how the human brain works and
there's all this data like that.
Only it turns out if you take that test
to a culture that actually needs to
judge distance for survival,
they don't have a problem seeing.
It's not an optical illusion to them.
It's just poor skill when we look at it.
So there are all of these hypotheses on
humans are studying college aged humans
like you're.
You're looking at orcas with floppy,
floppy fins and then are just making all
these judgments on whales and so I'm at
with this realization that so much of
our,
like your human physiology textbook,
that's not human physiology,
that shape that you're looking at have a
skeleton that's,
that's modern guy who's worn shoes his
whole life and walked on flat and level,
flat and level ground.
That's another cast.
You're not supposed to walk like flat
and level is the most weird abnormal
texture for you to ever walk on,
and yet you've probably only walked on
flat and level for like 99 percent of
your life.
Your ankle joint has a different shape
than someone who has walked in the
wilderness their whole entire life
because they use more parts just to get
walking done.
Use almost nothing to walk.
Walking is falling.
Like that's our.
That's our saying is sure.
For someone who sits in the chair most
of the time and walks on flat and level
in shoes that's falling.
Some people have an incredibly difficult
time going up hills.
Sure.
The different muscles and different.
One of the first times I went hunting,
I went hunting in Montana and we were
climbing up these hills.
That's used to be the great western
inland sea near,
uh,
it's the Missouri breaks.
And so it's this weird clay like
material that covers all the ground and
when you're walking up hill you're
sliding a lot down and everything is
kind of slippery.
So everywhere you're going,
you're constantly counterbalancing and
catching yourself.
And it's not like us and you get
exhausted like you think you're in
shape.
Like you could do all kinds of crazy
workouts and crossfit your brains out,
but then you go up these hills all day
and you're fucking tired and by the end
of the day you're starving.
You have this weird hunger for animal
protein to for animal protein and fat,
like fatty things and even pasta or any
like high calorie things like this
intense craving for because your body's
just doing all this breaking down of
tissue all day long.
You're stressing your body in a weird
way that you just don't get.
Like walking around the city
we've gotten.
We've gotten rid of everything.
Anything.
The only variable that we have left to
play with his intensity.
Like it's like,
well I'm walking on this.
I'll have to go faster.
I'll have to go harder because that's
the only thing that's left to respond to
it.
Like that's the thing with casts is if
you've.
If you've removed any other movement
that would allow you to do any sort of
cross training or use new parts in
different ways than all you have left to
do is the same thing harder or faster,
but yeah,
texture for people who study the human
kinetic chain,
like things like walking and like the
foot skin like you're going up hills and
shoes probably,
but if you.
If you didn't have shoes on,
that first level of of traction would be
at the skin,
which means your skin has to be strong
enough to carry the load of your body
here hands,
you know,
people do a ton of work with their upper
body,
but they won't actually bring the hand
skin along to the strength of the rest
of their body because everything's a
bar,
right?
It's like this flat uniform level never
occur in nature bar as opposed to
picking up things with texture and each
other's texture.
That kind of bite in the skin and then
your skin strengthens and then your arms
are stronger because.
Because that first level of caring or
picking up or hauling out or doing
anything is traction.
Traction between you and the earth,
human and the earth.
Animal on earth,
whether it's a hand or foot.
Yeah.
One thing I've never understood is I
understand it,
but I've never done it.
I've never agreed with it is guys who
put risk traps on and do all these
exercises.
So you're carrying weight that your
hands can support,
but you're kind of doing your body a
disservice or you're overloading your
joint 20 doing that,
aren't you?
Yeah.
Um,
because what's happening is they can't
get any stronger to carry that because
it's,
again,
it's this limited flat and round thing
like,
you know,
you can pick up your kettlebell or
whatever,
but as it's getting heavier,
it's the same handle.
So there's,
there's parts of you that are left out
of getting stronger because the
environment is repetitive.
So if you go out and hang from a tree,
if you were holding onto something that
kind of fit in a little bit,
then you would be able to carry with
your hands whatever you were also able
to carry with for the rest of the body.
There's got to be some sort of cross
training for the hands.
It can't just be that same
thanks.
So instead of just gripping like this
all the time,
you should do some stuff like this and
you should pull things and you should
be.
And texture.
Texture is,
it's not musculoskeletal,
it has nothing to do with the amount
your joints flex,
so.
So girth of a bar is one thing,
you know,
the size and the shape of the bar and
the angle.
That's one way of cross training the
hands,
but there's also the skin,
like your skin just not
strong enough because the things that
you are exercising with are these kind
of smooth man made fake things are not
anything that you would actually like.
This is the weight of a log.
It's like great.
Go pick up a log to.
We should pick up long.
You should pick up logs,
pickup some,
some rocks or something.
Or at least hall yourself up in a tree.
Every now and then instead of on a chin
up bar,
like in a gym.
Hm.
We need trees to climb up,
but if you fall down from the tree,
you're fucked.
Yeah.
Or are you.
I don't know,
maybe you've never really loaded.
Like I said,
the other thing would walls you're
fucked if you fall from a tree.
Well,
the same thing about,
you know,
dropping something on your foot.
You become a little bit more mindful.
You become more mindful.
My friend Cameron does this work out.
I think he does it once a week where he
takes a rock that's 135 pound rock and
he carries it up to the top of a
mountain and he doesn't want it two
ways.
Like sometimes he throws it in his
backpack.
He has like one of those,
a big oversized tenzing backpacks,
like with all the straps on it that you
would use for like carrying game out of
the woods.
He's a big l connor.
And to train his body to carry heavy
loads,
he just takes us 135 pound rock throws
in his backpack and goes up hills or
sometimes he just picks this rock up and
puts it on his shoulder and goes up
hills and just rotate shoulders and I
think in his eyes like anything you do
that's unusual or difficult and training
your body and training it in some way
that's going to sort of mimic what he's
going to have to do if he's hunting and
carrying an elk out of the forest.
It's like similar to that.
Yeah,
six law of specificity.
You want to get to it as close as
possible,
but he's also still carrying this
awkward weight and doing things in a way
that makes you your body like
compensate.
But that's.
But see,
that's the thing with posture,
why it's a modern construct.
Like to say that there's a safe way to
carry a rock really means that if I'm
only doing this one thing and then
sitting down the rest of the time,
that the only way that my whole body's
going to be trained is if I do my
training time symmetrically.
If you were just moving all the time,
kind of a nature,
you would balance out and actually.
Because you'd never encouraged.
You never encounter the same load twice
really.
So I have kids,
I have a two year old and a three old.
We've never had a stroller.
We've carried those 30 and 40 pounders
exclusively miles.
And so that was,
that was our big thing.
Right.
You know,
so everyone's like,
you're,
when you have kids,
a lot of times your workout changes
because there's just no more time
anymore.
It's like,
well you carry them and then they're
dynamic and they're moving,
which means it's not like it's not
holding a 30 or 40 pound ball,
right.
It's,
it's a different load because there for
30 and 40 pounds is distributed at their
whim based on what they want to look at
and where they want to go and they want
to go to this site now.
So they are,
they are strong little shits,
like they're strong,
they're really strong,
but they've been carrying themselves and
we've been carrying them.
So it's like there's been this
relationship,
I'm always strong enough to carry them
five miles.
No problem.
Wow.
Five miles,
five miles.
Wow.
That's very impressive.
Carrying anything that's 30 plus pounds,
five miles,
but you can't put down when you're like,
that's the thing.
It's like we've committed,
we're in the,
we're in the wilderness.
We will have to come out now.
Like my six year old is awesome.
She pulls full guard on your show,
wrap her legs around you and essentially
almost carries her homework and that's
part of it.
Right?
So since they've never been in a
stroller,
they know how to hold on to and they
could hold on.
I mean when they were like six or seven
months,
they were strong enough to hold on.
It could hang from their own hand.
Wait,
no problem.
That you had to give them the
environment to do that,
which was never put him in anything.
That's so,
so you like have engineered this in a
way?
Well I think it was,
it's been around for a really long time.
But yeah,
like that's like in your own personal.
My own personal life.
I've just a really do everything that I
recommend.
I've just done myself.
I do it as a workout.
I carry both of them.
Like when we go places and they get
tired.
I carry both my kids a six year old and
the four year old I always team up.
I have an 18 year old but I'm carrying a
six year old,
the four year old or hoist him up on my
shoulders and haul them around.
But yeah,
this is a really good workout if you,
you know,
you carry carrying 70 pounds and some
sort of a weird way,
you know,
you got like 40 on one hand,
30 on the other and you sort of balance
and amount,
but it balances out over time.
I mean,
I guess that's a thing with,
with loads the body,
they should balance out over time.
They don't always have to balance out
over an hour.
I found out something recently that
disturbed me.
I always throw my backpack,
I throw it over my right shoulder like
this and I walk around and it just sits
there.
But then when I throw it over my left
shoulder it slumps down and it's
awkward.
Like I can't carry it on my skin right
now.
But you know,
like my left shoulder doesn't know how
to keep it up.
And I was like,
well what the fuck is going on?
Why does it keep doing this?
Why does it keep falling over my left
one when I put on my right one,
boom,
it just locks in place there.
It's effortless,
but over my left one it's like a lot of
extra work.
So I started carrying it only on my left
one,
like,
you know,
pick up the slack bitch.
But it's odd,
like I think I'm in balanced in some
sort of strange way.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
the shape of your body is down on the,
on the cellular level,
you know,
they look at bones and people they can
tell who his right hand and you'll be
able to tell you right handed or left
handed.
That's how all that anthropological data
just.
Yeah,
it's bone robust tenicity the size and
the shape of your bone lets people know
what you did with your body while you
were here.
Well that's also why bounce in like
certain exercises like pictures and
stuff.
They get imbalanced because they're
always throwing with your right hand.
Like my friend Steve Maxwell,
he's worked with a lot of people that
have issues with their back and stuff
and like one of them was a kicker and he
fixed it all by making them kick with
the left leg.
It was like,
you're own kicking with your right leg
all the time.
Do you ever kick with your left leg?
Then I was like,
no.
Like
you need to do that.
Like you're,
you're,
you're loading up one side of your body
constantly all day and the other side is
getting virtually no movement in the
same direction.
So it's just going to have to start
doing.
And all of his problems went away.
Yeah.
You can't just do heavy,
high loads on one side all day long.
Is your sport like that can't be your
sport.
It has to a little bit better balanced.
But isn't that incredible?
Because I don't think pitchers,
I don't,
I really don't know what they do about
that now.
I think it's probably more people like
you now that are interacting with these
guys and teaching them things.
But I think for the most part they just
throw the one arm
they do.
And the thing with the thing,
with the picture data,
like in the CTCS,
um,
it's not just muscle,
like it's easy to correct a muscle
imbalance.
It's like,
Oh,
you clearly,
you can see that there's more muscle
mass on one side.
Their bone,
the bone itself is torked now.
So that the reason that you know if you
have enough,
if you wind up,
if you imagine winding up,
there's this great need for range of
motion behind you and your body is very
efficient.
If you are going to keep challenging the
muscles to get longer,
to stretch to that position,
it will just move the bone there so that
the muscles can go back to kind of their
regular length.
So now you have the same range of motion
in both arms,
but the range of motion isn't a
different location on your pitching arm
because you've twisted the bone there.
So that phenomenon of,
of your bones being shaped by what you
do is happening to all of us all the
time.
People will say like,
have tibial torsion,
you know,
like in my lower leg.
It's like,
yes,
your gait pattern has slowly wound your
bones so that your foot is no longer in
the same plane as it once was or would
have been.
So you already are an entirely different
shape than you would have been had you
been moving differently throughout your
life.
You're,
you're,
you're not just like more or less muscle
in shape or out of shape.
You're an entirely different shape.
Whoa.
So,
um,
I started doing martial arts when I was
a young boy and did it all throughout my
adolescent years through puberty.
That's probably my body sort of
developed to do those movements.
That's one of the reasons why when you
take people,
one of the big issues with a martial
arts,
some martial arts that have really
difficult for older people to learn and
kicking seems to be one of the hardest
ones.
For whatever reason your body just does
not want to learn that as an older
person.
But as a young person,
like my six year old,
her little hips are just so,
like loose.
She knows she can just throw her legs
around.
There's no resistance,
but old people,
it's very difficult getting into
properly with enough speed and,
and to,
to have impact.
But if you get someone that's the same
age has been doing it since there were
child there could do it really quickly.
It's was like there's something about
the body developing,
doing those movements.
Yeah.
You know,
zero to zero to five is the most where
you're the most malleable,
like your skeleton isn't
even set yet,
but then when you go from five to 15 and
probably all the way up to 20,
then you are much more malleable than
you will be after your.
Your bone,
your bone.
We say bone density because it's easiest
to measure,
but your bone shape and all that entails
is set really for life at that point.
So you know if you would squat,
so you probably squat a lot more.
At least if you're in a martial art,
a lot of times they're squatting put
into it,
but if you take someone who's been
sitting at their office,
you know,
using a toilet their whole entire life,
their hips have never articulated to
that degree that you're,
that you're asking them to.
And in the tradition of the martial art
that people who came up with the martial
art oftentimes live in entirely
different lifestyle.
Where they're shaped.
They're.
There are shapes that facilitate sports
better and the in the shape that
facilitates.
It tends to come from the areas that
create whatever the sport is that you're
talking about because anthropometric
dimensions are the size and the shape of
your body.
Sports and leverages that you create are
heavily dependent on anther prometric
dimensions and so your pelvis you might
not be able to kick because your pelvis
is shaped by not kicking like you have a
not kicking pelvis because you were a
non kicker.
You can't just all of a sudden start to
be a kicker any any more than the
pitcher can decide to not have it
twisted bone in his arm anymore after
throwing his whole entire life.
So if you develop your whole life as a
non kick and then someone tries to show
you kicking techniques,
is there.
Is there a way to open you up and make
you more pliable and make your body
adapt to those movements better?
I think that there is because you are
malleable really as a structure
throughout your entire life.
I just think that it's larger than do
this kick over and over and over again,
that there are ways to facilitate the
mobility of the entire structure.
So if it were me and I was trying to
teach them martial art,
it wouldn't just be the kick.
I'd be like,
what?
What do these that are good at kicking?
Like what are the other lifestyle
things?
It's,
it's about frequency.
It's not enough.
It's not enough load like not kicking.
You're constantly adapting to not
kicking.
So the amount that you kick is,
I mean how many kicks are you going to
practice 100.
100.
Like it's so it's so it's so it's too
small.
It's so small.
What you're asking to adapt to that.
There are ways to create change in shape
and bones and that there's evidence that
it really does happen throughout a
lifetime.
It's just the exercise paradigm is so
small to training paradigm is so small.
It's like if you want to become more
malleable,
you have to change everything that you
do all of the time and you will adapt to
that.
Do people have a built in limitation as
far as their flexibility or is it simply
a matter of the amount of time and
effort you spend trying to explain?
You expand your flexibility?
I don't think humans have a builtin
limitation from birth,
but I think that your range of motion
gets set really,
really early and we are in a mobilizing
culture like we a mobilizer.
Babies really like the whole culture
really doesn't work unless your kids are
quiet and still in someplace at the time
in which are the most dynamic and I'm
now people now,
you know,
we used to roll around in the back of
our station wagon,
but now kids are like locked in even
more for a longer period of time and
they have more casts on them now so
they're very,
very inflexible.
Extremely inflexible or the ranges of
motion are in way different planes than
they would be.
So like you can still have 50 degrees of
hip motion,
but it's all in front of you instead of
port of it being behind you.
Right?
Yeah.
That's one of the weird ones I'm in
teaching is teaching people to lift
their leg up and to move it.
Like in this range,
like whether it's a cross or this one is
even weirder.
Lifting your leg up,
what's called a hook kick.
You lift your leg up and bring it
across.
This way it's just a different movement
and a looseness of the hips and I've
talked to people about it and one of the
big copout as people go,
I'm not naturally flexible.
You're naturally flexible and I'm like,
man,
I don't know about all that.
I don't seem naturally flexible.
I see my mom,
I see my sister like they're not.
They're not any but I've done it my
whole life so I.
I've become.
But there was this guy that used to work
out at our gym and he was a really,
like I'm very dedicated athletes,
a pro football player who retired and
started getting into Jujitsu and he had
massive flexibility issues for a while,
but this guy was such a dedicated
athlete that he would get after
practice,
he would,
he would do his training and then he
would stretch just like painful
stretches.
You could see that guy putting way more
time in it and then like a year later
he's doing the splits and you know,
I pointed it out to everybody in the
class.
I go,
I don't want to hear anybody tell me you
can't get flexible because this fucking
guy got flexible in a year,
like in a year,
this guy was this giant,
250 pound like giant quads,
like all stiff from all these years of
dead lifting and all that jazz and this
guy figured out like,
hey,
in order to get good at Jujitsu,
I'm going to have to really stretch,
and we all used him as an example.
Okay,
now I know like it,
it can be done,
but you got to really do it and you've
got to do it.
It's gonna.
It's gonna suck and it's not going to
feel comfortable.
It's gonna.
You're gonna have to stretch that tissue
out.
Yeah,
it's frequency.
I mean,
I think the easiest way to say is it's
all changeable,
but you have to be super diligent.
It's about the amount of time that
you're asking your body to do something
and if you imagine the shape of whatever
kick you can do now,
like whatever small circle it is,
and then you imagine this,
the kick that you want to have your
kicks just have to.
You have to coax the edge of it.
It's like you're.
Your body's like clay,
right?
You're just a matter of you're just
doing the slow reshaping,
your slowly reshaping and and you want
to just be imagining the shape that
you're trying to make and you're just
pushing the limits of the tissue because
you,
you've been doing it so long,
you have the parts.
Your muscle mass becomes longer,
shorter as necessary.
The,
the orientation of the bone in its
socket and all those support issues like
those,
it takes a while to adapt.
Takes a year.
It's not like I've been doing this for
six weeks.
When is it going to get better?
It's like you're not doing it for 40
years,
so you just have to look about.
You have to look at it more in terms of
time,
like realistic time and physiology,
and I think anyone can really accomplish
some serious physical,
physiological,
physical transformations,
but again,
not in that one hour that they allow
themselves three times a week.
It's got to be bigger.
Everybody wants a pill.
Sure,
fucking Dr.
every time you seen him on TV,
he's pushing some God damn diet pill.
They dragged him in front of Congress
because of that shit.
He was lying about Miracle Diet pills,
but that's a real issue with our culture
is we want to.
We want to eat things to lose weight.
We want to put more food in our fat
faces and we just want,
oh,
this,
this diet is going to make you lose
weight,
but what what you're doing by telling
people that that you can have a pill and
lose weight is you're,
you're.
What you're doing is denying the reality
of change and that change requires time
and effort and you can't just pop
something in there and get a shot and
everything goes away and all your fat
shrinks away.
And like,
people that want to like,
there's this friend,
um,
she uh,
got liposuction and didn't need it.
I mean she might've been 20 pounds
overweight.
Like maybe if that,
like that's a few months of dedication.
That's it.
Just a few months of let's watch our
diet,
let's you know,
and you know,
she's got kids and Blah Blah Blah and
she,
you know,
has a business and blah blah blah.
She just doesn't have that much time.
But you gotTa fucking vacuum stuffed
under your skin and they sucked all the
fat out and now you've got to wear a
girdle and they going to wear these
compression shorts and shit.
And everything's all fucked up and lumpy
and like it's crazy.
Oozing postures,
a drain on her leg because the,
the,
the fact that they suck out of it,
like everything gets infected and it's
all fucking pussy and shit.
Like you're going to go through two
months of rehabilitation,
you're going to recover.
It's going to take you like,
yeah,
you look slightly thinner right away,
but at what cost.
But the instantaneous nature of the
gratification of just going to the
doctor or are going to suck it all out.
Right?
Like the same thing as the doctor
telling me,
Oh,
you're going to,
we're going to have to fuse her desk.
Like you're going to what?
Like wait a minute,
I'm moving around.
Everything seems to be.
There's no way to fix this.
It's just going to get worse.
Like they always say,
it's just gonna get worse.
Well,
if I continue to do the same shit that
made it bad,
it's just going to get worse.
Right?
Isn't there some sort of a way to change
that?
But nobody thinks about it that way.
Everybody wants instantaneous
gratification where there's a weird
space right now where we want,
we want to be better in the very same
habit,
doing the same things that got us to
where we are in the first place.
Like it's
so weird.
It's like when does that work?
Anywhere else where like this is,
this is what has happened,
this is the,
this is the ramifications of all those
things that you did.
So the solution,
the pill is really so that I don't have
to change any of those things that got
me there.
It's like everyone should take a class
in human physiology or something.
Well,
there's also the reality of life.
Dove work,
you know,
most people have a job that requires
them to stay in a spot and it's really
difficult to do anything about it.
I have this Jarvis desks,
not this one,
but uh,
over there and the other room that uh,
Jamie setup,
you press a button and it stands with
you.
So like as you were at your office,
you can do this and you can just go back
and sit down and you move around.
The idea is to give yourself like a
couple of minutes sitting a couple
minutes standing and keep moving like
Zach,
is that effective?
That's good.
Amazing.
So there's like a whole,
if you just talk about your office,
I'm not,
I like the standing workstation,
right?
So the sitting kills stuff sitting's
worse than smoking.
Then everyone's like,
I'm never gonna sit down ever worse.
Right.
I don't know if you chain smoke.
Well,
have you been changed sitting for a long
time?
What'd you chain smoke end chain set
than your far.
Well maybe it's smoking has been saving
your life by going outside for a smoke
break.
So small walks,
you know now like the literature is like
make sure you take a small walk every 20
minutes like that times perfectly with a
cigarette break.
And since it's not since it's the old
smoking,
so old smoking.
But could you imagine
someone telling you,
uh,
you know,
I'll,
I'll work in your office by gotta to
take a walk every 20 minutes like fuck
off.
You're not going to get anything done.
Well I,
you know what I tell people all the time
that they should do their phone calls,
walking,
like,
like make your,
save up your phone calls and then just
go out and just take a 20 minute stroll
or whatever.
And just gotTa stop right here.
Because I don't have service for.
Keep walking.
Yeah.
See I live in the cities all different
now.
I don't know where these things.
What will you,
where you live and you get cell phone
service.
I do everywhere I cell phone service
now.
We have in China right everywhere.
Even that can be good.
Has that bad,
bad for bees,
cell phone service.
You know what,
that whole emf thing,
they wanted to put some emf weapons up
in an hour in our woods there so that
it's like we've,
there's no literature that shows that
they're bad for the body.
So we're going to put some emf weapons
and was like,
what?
That's crazy.
Yeah,
I've seen some interesting studies.
Clearly it's doing something so the,
the easiest tissue to test his sperm
because you can get as much sperm to
test and you can,
you can.
It's a ethical I guess to expose it to
emf so they can take,
you know,
just gonna throw it away anyway,
so you can take us to sperm samples and
you can put one next to a phone or you
can have a guy where a phone on his hip
and the sperm is different after having
it.
So they don't know if it's the heat of
the device because there's a device in
your pocket,
you know,
a lot of people carry it right there in
their pocket or right there in their
shirt pockets,
you know,
um,
whether it's the heat or the EMF,
they haven't really broken it down.
And I've seen some,
some other smaller studies on,
on um,
uh,
fetuses,
you know,
where they make the mother have a device
and where a device to see what the cells
look like.
So the data isn't,
the data is pointing that there is some
sort of change all with all that kind of
stuff.
It's like the dose makes the poison.
How much,
what is the change significant.
Like what's gonna happen with that sperm
that's different.
Nobody knows any of that.
So I guess just say,
just say,
well,
use your phone.
I turn my phone off of air.
I put it on airplane mode if it's going
to be by my head when I go to sleep.
And other than that,
I don't keep it on my body or near my
body.
Why do you keep it by your head?
Well yeah,
like if it's,
if it's my alarm or whatever,
so I was like,
you can use it for an alarm,
just turn,
you can turn it off.
So that's not transmitted admitting
anything.
Right.
But is it's still generating heat?
Well it's not touching me anymore so
it's not all my skin.
But if you carry it in your pocket,
if you're carrying in your pocket,
it would still be.
It generates heat more I think when it's
transmitting
wonder if people just show up like years
now everyone has asked cancer
back pocket area ships are all aligned
but now they have asked answer.
I think like Sheryl Crow has brain
cancer and she was saying that they were
trying to attribute it to or possibly
attributed to when she was doing press
for her first cd was the old days of
cell phones and she did all of it
through her mobile phone.
She had it up to her head the entire
time and it's that side of her head that
she has the issue with.
I think that we,
we do a lot of stuff that we have no
idea how it's gonna,
you know,
trickle down later
about it.
Like everywhere we go,
you're experiencing wifi signals,
radio signals,
um,
you know,
I don't know.
How does the satellite thing work?
I mean you have to Kinda like have a,
an antenna or a dish that points up to
where the satellite is sending the
signal,
but that signal somehow or another
getting here,
whether it hits your dish or not,
is it getting to bodies?
We know that cell phone signals fuck
with bees.
Like that's one of the things that
they've figured out when they were
trying to figure out what's killing off
all these honeybees.
Most,
most things point towards pesticides,
but there is an disease,
but there's also some issue that we
might be constantly fucking with their
navigation and their ability to
communicate.
It's almost like living next door to
people that are just playing loud rock
music all day.
Do you survive?
Yes you do.
But does it fuck with the quality of
your life?
Yeah,
it does.
You know,
and because bees have this weird way of
communicating with each other that seems
to be interfering or with the cellular
systems that we have seems to be
interfering with that.
Well,
and they've shown it was sonar and the
whales,
you know,
everything is just messed up by these
things,
these,
that we're creating
for whatever,
you know,
they're,
they're tangible,
they're invisible.
I think it's just because they're
invisible.
We just don't think of visible things
having any sort of impacts like wrap me
up in something I want to head pounding
against my head.
But if I can't see it,
how much could it really be harming me.
Meanwhile,
every everyone's writing up this huge
list of things that are wrong with them
and what they're searching for and we're
just flapping on uh,
well it's just idiopathic or genetic or,
or whatever has no cause no known cause
it just happens.
It's normal.
And it's like,
yeah,
but.
So our cell phone towers or chairs and
all this other stuff.
Well,
there's a weird feeling that you get
when you get to a completely deserted
place,
like a real wilderness place with total
quiet,
no cell phone service,
no nothing.
Yeah.
This is weird.
Like absence of input that you feel
different.
They're like,
wow,
this feels weird.
Like I gotta get Outta here.
Desolate feels like so it's so
unforgiving.
It just doesn't give a fuck if you're
around or not around.
It's like that silence for whatever.
It's almost like people that are afraid
to be alone,
like you have to be out at parties all
the time.
It got to constantly be talking to
people on the phone when you're alone
and you have to deal with your own
bullshit.
When you go to those will true
wilderness areas with no cell phone
service.
It's like,
oh,
okay.
A little scary.
This is real.
You know,
we try to go dark like two days a week.
Dark,
dark wood in the diamond family.
Yes.
The Bowman Bowman family goes dark two
days a week and you just go out and
spend more time outside than inside and
that's a great place about having great
thing about having the wilderness.
There is like huge trees,
old growth trees have been around for a
long time and one time it was windy and
trees were falling
down.
It's like trees are falling down.
We are in the wilderness.
It's insane.
Well,
it happens.
It happens.
Yeah.
You say that until you get hit by a tree
that I've avoided that.
You don't have that laissez faire,
but it happens.
It happens.
Maybe A.
Yeah.
Fucking hit by an old growth tree.
Way to go.
We,
we were out in one fell and it sounded
like a gunshot went off and we had
determined that it was a tree that fell
who was up in Canada,
but it was like boom.
We're like somebody out here shooting.
Like what the fuck is that?
And the guy that we were with,
like I don't think so.
I think that's a tree with a felling
trees or no towel.
Just fucking had its time.
What happens when was blown like,
that's enough.
I'm tapping out bone and it just came
down.
I mean,
you find them all over the place,
right?
There are so many trees,
but that reality that this,
this thing has been there before
Columbus ever get near America.
I mean especially where you are in the
Pacific northwest when you're dealing
with some of those trees,
like a thousand years old,
almost the whole planet used to be
wooded,
right?
We've cut everything down.
It was almost all wooded.
You couldn't even.
You couldn't even walk.
I'm like up in up in British Columbia,
up there,
I was so thick.
The all of the trees falling down for
years.
All that Moss and stuff that you're
walking on is just old mushed up,
rotted trees,
but you couldn't even just walk through
the woods.
There are trees everywhere and they've
cut everything down and so much of the
desert that's in the middle of the
United States or from those from the
fires,
like when they started using lumber for
oceans,
ocean ships like all of the.
The British military ships came from
lumber from the Pacific northwest,
and they are at,
once they realized that they had that
commodity they are using like wasn't
mink Mikan Otter,
otter offers where what brought everyone
to the Pacific northwest.
They cleaned all the mountain and like
what can we ship now if they would,
and then they shipped it out and they
were making,
they were milling it.
So when you mill it,
you know,
the mass of the tree is lost in between
the boards.
So it's um,
a sawdust and so sawdust was clogging
all the rivers and there was a big fire
and then the fire just went across the
United States because there was no
natural water barriers anymore.
It just burnt it down,
kind of like your cartilage,
right?
You can,
you can use some cartilage grows back,
but if you take it all the way down to
the bottom to the base cells,
no more's coming back.
So that's really where that,
that rock,
it's really cool.
Have you ever used a pellet grill?
You don't.
A pellet grill and this is company.
A bunch of companies make them,
but one of them that I'm friends with,
his green mountain grills and these
pellet grills,
they take hardwood pellets and it's
basically saw dust and they press it in
the natural sugars.
Allow it to maintain the shape of.
It's almost like kitty litter.
If you have a cat.
I have a cat.
We use this pine.
Literally it looks real similar to the
stuff that you put it in this pellet
grill.
It's all digitally regulated so it can
keep the temperature at 200 degrees.
Can You keep it for like seven hours
with this like pot of of pellets and
it's like super efficient and it's a
smoker.
It's essentially a grill slash smoker,
but instead of like,
have you ever used an old school smoker?
Like one of those big barrel smokers,
those are pain in the ass.
Like you got to like regulate the
openings,
the valves and make sure you get the
right amount of temperature.
You've got to keep thermometers in
there.
And in the old days it was super
difficult to figure out how hot
everything was,
you know?
And then they figured out how to put
meat thermometer is actually in the meet
and have digital ones had come outside
and give you a reading.
But these pellet smokers essentially
they take all that hardwood sawdust that
used to be just waste and compress it
into these little pellets and then use
it to cook with smart.
Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
And it tastes really good too when you
cook it with because you were actually.
It's real.
It's not like that's the big issue with
using any sort of lighter fluid or
anything like those.
Those ones that are like easy match,
charcoal briquettes,
those chemicals and those things.
And you can taste it.
You smell it.
Yeah.
But this stuff,
you don't smell any of it.
So they're there,
you know.
But it is,
that's the reality of
chopping down trees just looks gross and
it makes you feel sad when you see it.
But your house is warm because he
chopped down trees.
Yeah,
it's,
yeah,
it's a cutting.
It's sad to be up there and don't drive
by a forest that's not there anymore.
Yeah,
those cut blocks was gigantic chunks,
but they kind of regulate that.
Right.
Like they only allow you to do it in
certain spots.
Then they regrow them and.
Well,
but they're regrowing Americans.
It's the same thing with any sort of
management.
Like they're being replanted with stuff.
It's going to be cut down into different
kinds of tree.
It's like a non native kind of tree.
It's the fast growing kind.
Right.
So I was trying to get it up and it's
like a commodity,
a commodity.
So get it planted and get it back up so
we can cut it down again.
But that old wood,
there's nothing like old growth.
It's just been around forever.
Yeah.
There's nothing like being in those
forests to.
Because you really do get that sense
that while this was here long before the
wheel or long before rather I'm the
engine or long before boats came over
here.
I mean this stuff out before the wheel.
Sixty zero,
6,000
year old trees,
right?
No.
So I don't think so.
What's the oldest tree?
I don't know.
Let's find out.
What do you guess?
If you had to guess,
it'd be like a sequoia or a redwood or
something.
How old do you think it would be?
There's trees.
Whoa.
Methuselah,
a brittle cone.
Pine tree from California's white
mountains is thought to be 5,000
years old.
The oldest non non conal will know what
that means.
Non clonal tree in the world.
The exact location of the normal trusted
is.
Oh,
it's kept secret for its protection.
Huh?
There's a tree that people are so gross.
You have to not tell them where the old
tree is because they'll go cut it down.
Smoking chair out of the tree.
Yeah.
Some asshole will go and use it to make
his headboard.
That stupid tree.
Huh?
Five thousand years old.
So that's a good answer.
So that's a God damn old tree.
That's probably the wheel.
And there's probably wheels circles all
around it.
Yeah.
Um,
but that's just being around something
that predates most of human history.
Just knowing that this thing was a seed
and that seed became this tree and it's
just seeing this entire world changed
during the time that it's been living
and breathing in carbon dioxide and
breathing out oxygen.
Very freaky.
That's something you get with old growth
trees that you're not going to get with
those cut blocks that are reef
refurbished with these new little shitty
pine trees that are little tags on them
and stuff.
Yeah,
it's kind of fucked.
That's just a weird thing about people.
We just,
we,
if we don't put regulations on stuff,
that's why it's really cool.
Like a place like a.
have you ever been to boulder,
Colorado?
They don't really allow people to build
like the.
You don't see any apartment buildings in
the mountains you don't see like they,
they have a very strict amount
of construction that they allow in and
they're very strict about it and they
buy up space on people of like spaced
land that's for sale.
Like Boulder County will actually buy
that land and make sure that it remains
open space.
So there'll be given ever build on it,
be kind of have to do that.
Keep people from fucking the whole thing
up.
You know,
wonder why no one wants to go to Alaska.
I think the last frontier,
there's some space up there.
Yeah,
with everyone's scared of bears.
That's true.
I'll ask.
It's freaky.
Alaska is the law.
It's like the wild west.
It is like the wild west up there.
The people are really cool though.
Have you spent time in Alaska?
No.
My husband had a big motorcycle trip.
They did like a big motorcycle trip.
I'm like all around there and they were
just in some kind of back country and it
was like everyone here,
is this like hardy?
They are.
They are like the cowboy,
whatever that equivalent spirit is there
going there because there's this less
rules,
more space,
more quiet.
We went to the movies at midnight and it
was bright outside.
This is fucking strange.
It was in the middle of July.
It was really weird.
Like we,
we did a comedy show up there.
We got out of the show.
It was two,
3:00
in the morning.
Bright out,
see everything.
It's very strange and the people up
there there are so it's like there's a
as a sense of community,
even in the city like anchorage that you
don't really see in a lot of cities down
here because their reality is,
yeah,
well every now and then a moose comes
into town and kicks the shit out of some
people at a supermarket or a bear
attack.
Someone that's in the wrong place,
the wrong time or you know,
it's just the reality that they live in.
They all have to kind of band together
because every now and then if you see a
car broken down the side of the road,
like you get out and help that person
because that could be you.
Right?
Whereas if you're leaving here and you
get on the one on one,
you see some guy broken down,
you don't even think for a second,
let me pull over.
There's 100 million people drive by.
Wrong.
No one's thinking,
let me go help that guy.
But if you're in Alaska and that's the
only car you've seen for 20 minutes,
you pull over.
Hey you okay?
Like what's going on?
Like you need a call,
it's a.
there's a sense of community because of
their harsh conditions because the
environment they're in.
Yeah,
you need people.
You really do need a tribal situation.
If you have,
you're spread out a little bit,
you know you have your,
your claim or your space,
but when you need help it's going to
have to be some other person's gonna
have to come help
but don't think it's kind of healthier
to be in a place where there's like,
you know,
the term diffusion of responsibility,
the idea being that it's easier to
attack someone in front of a thousand
people than it is in front of one person
because one person feels obligated to
help.
Whereas a thousand people say someone
should jump in and do something but
nobody does anything because they don't
feel like they have to because there's
so many other folks.
Isn't that Kinda like what you get if
you're in a big city as opposed to like
maybe where you live or maybe Alaska or
just a.
there's a,
there's a number
that's manageable.
Yeah,
I mean I,
I like,
I like the town that we live in.
I grew up in a small town and then I've
been,
I was in southern California for a long
time and it never really felt connected
as easiest word,
but now that I'm out there in a little
bit more rugged or wilderness,
you know,
I,
I feel I feel safe,
safe knowing that there are neighbors or
community members,
I feel more,
more safe there.
I think that I feel in the big city.
Yeah,
totally makes sense.
Uh,
yeah.
I think big cities are a new thing,
you know,
as far as human beings,
like our DNA,
we've only had them for a few hundred
years.
Yeah.
What's the biggest city?
It's probably something in China,
like as far as population wise,
I mean la is kind of huge,
but it's really spread out.
It's not.
I mean it's a city,
but it's a weird thing.
It's like a giant suburb,
you know,
the look at the city aspect of La you
got like downtown La is what we think of
as a city,
but because of the fact that there's
earthquakes,
everything is only one level out here
are two levels at most except for
downtown and you have a few office
buildings here and there,
but if you look at the landscape,
it's a lot of like flat things.
I would say probably the biggest is like
Singapore or something like that.
What is it?
Hong Delhi.
India has got at least 25 million.
Do you know your neighbors really well?
My neighbor is a Douche bag.
So you do.
I know one neighbor,
uh,
I know a couple neighbors.
There's a few people that live on my
block that I know that I'm friendly
with.
It's wet.
People know,
go outside.
I think that it might even be like less
about numbers and more about how many
people go outside or not because it
seems to me like in,
in big cities,
um,
w or even suburbs of big cities,
like everyone is pulled their car to
their garage.
They close their garage and then they're
in their house and then um,
if they're outside,
they're in their backyard with her,
you know,
small family that there's not these
large communities of people that are
interacting outside.
So maybe maybe you could have that kind
of that safety or you know,
everyone taking responsibility for
people that you live with because you
consider yourself living with them
because you see them and you're next to
them in some,
in some place.
But I'm like,
if you're in Alaska,
I imagine that even if you were in your,
even if you're up there by yourself,
you're still spending so much time
outside because you still have to get so
much for yourself I imagine or just get
out to go pick it up wherever it's being
shipped in.
Well,
there's definitely that.
It's much more expensive to get things
up there and get food and groceries and
things along those lines.
Especially the more rural you get,
the more problematic it is to get things
delivered.
No.
Um,
when I say my neighbors a Douche bag or
something bad guys just kind of goofy,
but there's some people in my
neighborhood that are very cool,
like,
you know,
I see them and it's nice.
It's nice to have a community where,
you know,
you go up the street and you see,
hey man,
what's going on?
What are you doing?
You're still working on that.
Oh that's cool.
Blah Blah Blah.
So it's nice like you have like this
little sort of relationship with.
But I didn't choose these people.
I just moved in and I got lucky that
some of them were okay and became
friends with some along the way.
But it's like ideally I've always said
the really smart thing to do would be
get together with all your friends and
loved ones and say,
Hey,
let's all live in this area.
Let's all move to this one street.
Is that possible to do like,
let's get the other.
But nobody ever really does that.
They always say like,
I've had 15 of those conversations with
my friends and with my friend Brian.
He just moved out in my neighborhood
didn't.
And I'm like,
come,
come look on my block.
And it's like fucking guy moved like 10
miles away.
I'm like,
why did you move over there dummy?
Oh my wife looks to be close to the
grocery store,
like fucking grocery store.
You're going to get in your car anyway.
Dummy isn't getting you car for 30
seconds or three minutes.
Is it really that much of a difference?
And it maybe that was the idea like with
neighborhoods that you would be living
with people like,
you know,
you're all going the same place for work
and everyone goes to same school and.
But now your neighborhood is just full
of all.
Like it's such a,
it's such a transient time.
And,
and also big houses,
I think,
you know,
I'm in New York,
I have friends who they go out to eat
for most of their meals right there.
Houses are large and so they're forced
by lack of space.
Again,
it's kind of one of those space things
where you have to go out and commune
with other people and you have your
seven favorite places and then by
default those became.
Come,
you're a little community,
but here you can.
You can sustain yourself entirely within
your,
your house,
your compound,
and it's just made it so we don't have
to really interact with anyone anymore.
That's a big thing with people.
They like to be sustained and they like
to have all of their stuff that they
need.
I mean,
that's what.
That's the prepper instinct,
right?
I've got enough food here for a year,
like everybody's got this idea that if
the shit goes down,
I'm going to be fine.
I'm going to just start piling.
Just have a gun turret on my roof,
I'm going to be fine,
but I live in,
in New York City I think is the worst
case scenario because people like I have
a friend who lives in New York.
You can't even put his golf clubs in his
apartment.
He's got no room.
He used to put it all in storage,
so if he wants to play golf is to go to
the storage place and open up his little
spot with a key and go in and get as
junk and like,
oh,
what are you doing?
Like you're living in a box.
Yeah.
My Post apocalypto is less about
hoarding,
you know,
like food or whatever.
It more about assembling a team.
Like I'm looking for skill sets because
a skill set you can take on the road and
produce something with that skill set
that is necessary.
So I don't really care how much what you
got in your garage or how much canned
food you have.
I care about like show me how fast you
can clean a fish who can make medicine
on herbs.
Like that's,
that's kind of more my.
That's those are the applications taking
now.
Sonata herbs,
any medicine,
any good that you can make other herbs
you just laying around.
Sure.
What have you ever made?
Well,
I mean there are,
there's all sorts of things you can make
an artist.
Can you make a mud pack?
I do.
You know,
do you know of the things that are in
nature that you can,
that you can take?
What can you eat?
What's edible?
Like basic stuff like that.
Like what?
What is out here that people have known
about for forever that no one knows
about anymore?
Like how,
how much of people,
how many Irish people started with the
potato famine because no one knew
anything about the plants that were
sitting right there that they could have
sustained themselves on the entire time.
Sure.
Eaten plenty of edible stuff.
They just didn't have the thing that
they had always eaten beforehand.
Really?
Sure.
That seems like ridiculous.
There's plenty of food mass there to
eat,
but if the skill set is gone,
then it's really easy to kill yourself.
Trying to figure it out for the first
time.
I'm sure you've seen survivor man.
You've seen that show less drought duck.
I opened my eyes for watching that show.
Watching how easy it is to not get food
like you think,
wow.
The guys in the woods,
plenty of stuff to eat out there and
they seemed like foraging for food and
trying to figure out how to like kill a
squirrel with some sort of a rock that
drops a little thing that he hits the
switch and the rock falls on his head.
Yeah.
Not so good.
It doesn't really work that well.
Who is that guy that John?
Is it John mcclane is the guy who went
out in the woods and then died in the
bus.
They made a movie out of it into the
wild so that everyone's like the
hypothesizing about like his,
you know,
his death and like,
oh,
he must've eaten this particular
planning got poisoned and all the wild
food experts aren't so he starved to
death.
It's very simple.
He starved,
he starved himself to death.
Like one of the reasons humans have such
a long juvenile period compared to any
other primate is getting food is hard
and it takes a really long time to be
taught how to get it.
Like to have this information handed
down into to get the skill,
the muscle if you will,
to be able to do it and you expend so
much energy trying to get it that you
have to eat not only to cover that
energy but enough to go beyond beyond
that a little bit.
And then if you're,
you know,
making kids or whatever,
then there's all this extra stuff and
it's very hard and no one has ever done
it ever.
Yeah.
We really got soft when it comes to
that,
the ability to feed yourself without a
supermarket.
It's very monumentally difficult task to
do for the average person.
That movie really pissed me off because
they twisted the into the wild.
They twisted the ending because in the
movie he eats a poisonous plant and he
gets sick and he dies.
He missed misidentified as the wrong
plant and his liver toxic and he dies.
Right?
But the reality is he did starve to
death because it's fucking hard to get
food,
right?
Like if you've ever gone hunting like
this.
One of the things that my friend Brian
Count and I first realized the first
hunting trip that we went on.
Lucky we went with this guy,
Steve Rinella is his famous hunter and
we.
But we're like Jesus,
like how the fuck did they do this
before they had guns?
Like we have guns and it's hard.
We have guns and scopes and binoculars
and a trained hunter and we know the
territory and we have,
we have a tags which like,
so they know there's in the area,
there's all these like things that are
on our side and it's still a fucking for
days with no success.
I feel like if you didn't have food with
you and you were going on these days
with no success,
you would be fucked.
Like you would start.
Like.
It could be really easy to starve to
death.
Like real.
That's with a gun.
Like with a gun.
It's easy to start without a gun.
When you hear about someone that's like
survived in the woods by themselves for
like 20 years,
like eating frogs and shit.
You like what?
How did that guy do it?
Like that?
To be like touch and go almost everyday.
Very few stockpiles.
Very.
Let me.
How much can you store?
You can only store like a couple days
worth of vegetables or plant matter
before that starts to go bad meat
depending on the temperature.
Usually only good for.
Unless it's freezing cold out,
you know,
it's not good for more than a couple of
days like you.
You have to constantly be on the move,
which is why cities weren't really
figured out until we figured out how
stockpile shit.
Once they fail,
stockpile shit and like,
okay,
we have a,
a grain silo,
we have enough food for a week.
Hey,
somebody should invent a way to make
music out of a box.
You know,
let's make a piano.
Like all that much of free time on her
hands.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's.
That is the container container.
I think of container free life is kind
of like my,
my goal,
but isn't it kind of a catch 22?
It's like you need society and culture
in order to figure out how to make a
computer,
which allows you to learn about how to
live in the wild.
You know what I mean?
You need,
you need education in order to figure
out what's going wrong with the human
body,
by living in this sedentary lifestyle
that you have to go through this
sedentary lifestyle to get that
education,
to figure out that it's not good for
you.
Yeah.
Well we've been in.
Again,
I mean that's what I could.
Damien is like we're stockpiling
information right,
and now we've got to figure out a way to
distribute it so it requires a whole new
society.
Like that's part of what civilization is
to,
is,
is someone knows something that you
don't know and that you might want to
know that you find valuable so you can
go do some of his work for him.
So he'll tell you.
Do you think that ultimately the,
the pattern that most people have chosen
this like nine to five in a box and then
still sat in the car drive,
is that going to be,
do you think will will realize somewhere
down the line that that likes smoking is
like really bad for you and we should
try to phase that out and try to.
Or do you think we're so caught up in
this idea of achievement and,
and our,
our momentum is so in that direction
that will never pull away from it?
I,
no,
I think,
I think that we will.
I mean,
I think that,
uh,
like you with European countries playing
around with things like four day work
weeks,
you know,
how,
how much work it doesn't take as much as
much time as you're going to work.
You're probably not working at some
point.
Someone I
hope is going to stand up and say I
could do my job like in three hours a
day.
And I think um,
as people are,
you know,
as,
as businesses are laying off,
people are doing enforced furloughs,
you know,
where they're saying,
well you now have four days to get the
same job done and you're gonna have to
take a 20 percent pay cut.
I think people are accepting that
because now they get this extra day.
They're actually better for it.
They might have less money,
but at home,
you know,
I think that if you've had some health
issues usually end up valuing your
health a little bit more.
It's always after,
I don't know if the up and comers will
see it that way,
but then for the up and comers,
there's not a lot of jobs for those up
and comers.
There's not even,
there's not even the option for nine to
five work for so many people now who did
what they were supposed to do,
you know,
when they went to school or whatever and
they got a trade or a job,
like there's no place for them,
so then they're going,
well I'll go back to school and try to
get a better job.
So I think everything.
I think everything we're to transition,
a lot of things are gonna change and I
think the work day in general with the
commute,
with the like digital commute,
people being able to work from their
computers wherever they are.
Eventually corporations will see that
it's cheaper.
The cheaper for them to still make the
same products,
paying people less,
but people get more free time.
Yeah,
but people are always going to want
more.
That's the thing.
It's like,
I think if you could tell someone,
hey,
I can do the same job for three hours a
day,
they will be like good.
That way.
I saved money.
Like,
no,
but we don't doing the same job.
If I'm doing the same job,
you're making the same amount of money.
Yeah,
but you only working three hours a day,
eight hours a day,
but I'm getting the same shit done,
but we don't really reward people sort
of.
Well,
some jobs do,
but most jobs it's about the amount of
hours you put in.
Yeah,
well I think that that person know who
said I can do it in three hours a day is
going to be replaced by someone who does
like you'll just keep working.
You'll find someone who can do the job
faster and for less,
and the only thing keeping people who
don't do that in their seats is a maybe
the law at a certain point.
Like if who you can fire and who you
can't fire if people are tenured or or
whatever that.
Hasn't that been the transition for like
the last 30 or 40 years where you're
just paying people less relatively
speaking,
you know,
the dollar is,
is different than what it was,
but aren't we paying people less who are
working?
Wait.
Like who doesn't work like seven days a
week who goes home and doesn't still
have their email on and still answering
emails.
I think that they're getting.
I think that they're getting a lot more
work out of people for what they used to
pay and that the fact they are paying
people less.
That is an issue.
I have a friend who has an issue with
his work because once he's done working
he will not answer emails.
He's like,
when I'm done,
I'm done and he's,
he's successful enough so that you can
kind of pull this off,
but it's a real issue that we were
trying to reach you all day.
He's like,
I was done.
I'm done working.
When I'm done,
I shut my email off and I go places
without cell phone service and like,
you know,
he's like,
well,
what's going on?
Am I working for you guys 24 hours a
day?
Like,
like if they send him an email at like
10:00
at night,
they get upset if you respond to it in
the morning,
like I sent you this at 10:00
at night.
He's like,
fuck you.
Fuck,
okay.
You don't own me.
Right?
This is,
this is what we're doing.
I mean he's in a weird position because
he's a without outing him.
He's a big wig so his,
his situation is very strange but his
stance is not.
His stance is like the stance that a lot
of people would like to take.
Like when the fucking day is over,
it's over.
You don't own me all through the night
with email,
but that's like sort of creeped into
people's life space.
Yeah.
Do you ever work with a company like
Zephyr company ever come to you and
said,
hey,
like we would like to ultimately like
from the beginning of our company would
like to engineer this thing to be like a
healthier environment for our employees.
Like what is a way we can get the most
amount of productivity,
but also keep people as healthy as
possible and give them an environment
that's more conducive to just being an
active healthy person.
Yeah,
sure.
You know like what are the.
I mean there are simple,
simple things that people can do.
Employers can do to provide their
employees with a healthier version,
I guess of what?
Of the nine to five.
You don't have to sit like roving desks.
That was a big one.
Not,
not having everyone at the same desk.
It's like going into the same desk every
single day is an issue.
It's an environmental killer.
Like you're looking at the same wall.
You're looking in the same.
Put our go to picture my daughter more
worried for you and there's my golf club
Monaco.
More thing I put here about the things
like you just are just so attached to
their people working.
Yeah.
What keeps you working as buying new
shit?
Know,
like the thing at the end of the week
I'm going to get that purse.
Woo.
That watch I've got my eye on you.
That's what keeps you going.
Otherwise I'm like,
why the fuck am I doing this?
Especially jobs,
they don't like.
Rewards are critical.
Right?
But then it turns out that they don't
even like the reward that much because
it's just onto the next reward.
How do we fix this?
Can I have a community that I am taking
up?
Okay.
She was opening a call your community up
north?
Yeah.
Take applications for you.
Well,
um,
I have applications or for my poke post
apocalypto team,
but yeah,
really banking on that.
Well,
you know what it is.
I just,
I really feel like I,
I,
it's like with shoes,
I wear regular shoes my whole entire
life.
And then you switched to something
minimal and you didn't even know how
they,
how your feet were feeling all day long.
It's very hard to sense how something is
limiting you until you take yourself out
and away from it.
It's like going camping.
Like everyone feels better when they go
camping and they're out hiking.
It's like,
I feel so good.
This thing that I had this chronic
headache,
this vision problem,
the,
this irritation with my family or
whatever it is.
When you go outside and you can't,
like all of a sudden it's different.
You've,
you've changed it up enough where it's
different.
Well,
I feel like that indoors now after being
outside so much,
um,
after spending so much time,
I'm like,
I can feel this chair right now.
I haven't sat in a chair continuously in
probably two years.
This was the only time you've sat.
Now I don't have furniture.
I'm like,
I got rid of my couch.
Right?
So we should.
I know now you know,
this show just took a turn.
You're a crazy person.
You have a couch and don't have a couch
and watch netflix sitting on the floor
in front of my laptop.
You sit on a floor like some sort of
barbarian for real,
for real.
Do you have cable tv at home or you just
one of those Weirdos?
Weirdos.
I get everything in.
I mean,
I like Netflix and stuff,
but I don't have Netflix as a guess.
I love Netflix.
I love it.
You can,
you can watch anything.
You don't need cable TV pretty close to.
You can find just about anything that
you want to watch.
But you know,
I don't,
I,
I'm,
I'm a worker.
Like I work a lot.
I'm very busy.
Um,
I participate in society so it's like
how can I,
how can I do all those things and,
and keep my pelvic shape in the low back
shape that I wanted and the strength
without having to go to do those things
separately from my regular life.
So I just sit on the floor.
I mean you've outsourced the work to
your most of your muscular system,
to your couch.
You have books.
How did you write those books?
On my laptop.
Did you,
how'd you sit in many different ways
like,
and not in one just,
you know,
cross legged laying on my stomach.
Sometimes they'll sit in a chair or I'll
stand at the counter.
My,
your buck.
It would if,
if you work that way exclusively,
but,
but not if you spent 20 minutes.
There you go do that and call it a yoga
pose.
Right?
Well,
someone would,
someone would call it some animal's name
was right?
Yeah.
So you just move around in different
ways.
Nothing completely sedentary or static.
Yeah,
and it's because I don't think that
we're,
you know,
we say we're too sedentary and it's like
I would say that you have too much
repetitive geometry which are different,
which is different,
you know,
so it's like you got to get out of your
couch and exercise.
I would say maybe you just get out of
your couch.
Maybe you keep watching Netflix.
Just sit cross legged on the floor.
Just put your legs out in front of you
because that is movement.
That is exercise.
It's just not in a special clothing.
In a class,
in a gym.
I go over my friend's house and they
have chairs.
No,
my kids freaks.
they are.
They're a little freaky for everyone
else,
but they are now.
They've never been sick.
I've never been sick.
No.
What is that?
Got Alien Kids.
You don't bring them anywhere.
Travel all over the world because you
are a filtration system and movement is
your biggest changer
and most people don't move at all.
They're too busy trying to figure out
how to not be stick.
Stick with these clogged up filters like
your whole lymphatic system depends on
movement.
A function like the biggest physical
movement portion of your immune system
depends on movement.
It doesn't have its own pump.
It uses the muscular.
What do you mean by that?
Like your immune system relies on
movement.
Yes,
your lymphatic system,
right?
So that's,
that's what's taking your cellular waste
and then moving it out of your body.
It's like it's.
It's laying right next to your arterial
and venous system.
So as muscles work,
they pump the blood over to the working
tissues and then it kind of washes
everything away.
So your lymphatic system doesn't need a
pump because why would it need a pump?
Why would you not be moving?
Why would a human not be moving?
Why would an Orca not be swimming in the
ocean?
It's because you have these parts of
your body that are movement dependent
because movement is something that
humans should be doing all of the time.
It's only in recent times that,
that we haven't needed to move.
So then these systems that are movement
dependent is
Kinda fail.
Yeah.
But my kids get sick and my kids move a
lot.
They do.
They do gymnastics classes,
exercise classes,
and they're in school and they're doing,
I mean,
what?
Are you kids going to school?
No.
Yeah,
I mean I might.
My three and a half year ago
it started in preschool,
but he's in a nature school,
right?
So it's all outside nature.
School side.
People are freaks.
We're going deep here.
What does this mean in nature?
School school?
It's um,
it's been around for like 15 years where
they're,
they don't have a building.
They do all their work outside.
They don't have a building.
No.
So what happens when it rains?
You go to school,
go to school and you know,
humans.
And what happens?
People live in the woods.
So you just use an umbrella.
No read under a tent.
No,
they're,
they're not doing that traditional kind
of sitting and reading and working with
paper.
They're learning edibles and their
learning.
I mean they're hiking and they're moving
and they're doing their math,
you know,
buy,
get this many branches and how to build
a fire.
And so you teach the kids to be grizzly
Adams.
Kind of.
Yeah.
This is fascinating.
How many kids go to your school with
your kids?
Well,
I think there's 10,
12,
10,
12 woodsy.
People that come down with like leaves
in their hair and not really.
I am the woods easiest.
You're the woods,
the woods where they are not,
you're not very what?
You seem totally normal to me I'm
totally almost normal.
Yes.
I'm totally normal.
I just like kids move,
like movement.
There's movement and then there's
exercise and they're two different
things and you know,
like gymnastics and like taking these
movement classes is not the kind of
movement that I'm talking about,
you know,
like recess and stuff that that's a
certain amount of movement.
But you know,
like the,
like
my kids move all day long.
I know.
Everyone's like,
yeah,
my kids when they're so they're active,
they're kids.
I'm like,
no,
I'm talking about like my kids will walk
two to three miles a day and they could
hang and climb and suspend themselves.
You know,
by the time they're one,
they move more like monkeys.
They're very confident and strong and
capable because they've been put into
challenging environments and they have
never.
They don't have chairs or anything.
They said no.
He goes eat.
We eat at a low table.
Sat on the floor with a low table.
Japanese style.
Yeah.
The bulk of the world doesn't have
furniture.
I know it seems radical that I don't
have furniture,
but the bulk of humans right now on the
planet don't have furniture.
Like you have furniture.
It's a real.
Your.
The weirdo also ruled the world.
Well,
that's the thing.
That's true TV.
Probably couches.
Yeah.
So you really do have no furniture in
your house?
Well,
I mean I have to core,
but no,
I don't have couches.
Sleep.
We sleep on pads on the floor.
On the floor.
No pillows,
pillows,
north your pillows.
A cast.
Do you think your heads should be laid
out in front of you like that whole
entire time?
Right?
You have a pillow underneath your head
between your shoulders and you sleep on
your back.
I sleep.
I move constantly because it's never
really comfortable.
So in that way,
in that way,
Mike,
my,
I move at night like just like any other
animal.
You're going going,
going back to the roots I think for
disease and health yet is.
I think it's required.
Do you ever go on the road and staying
at a bed and go,
fuck,
this is awesome.
I do.
And the couches Galore when I'm on
vacation,
my husband had to like turn on the
television,
love it,
but it's like dessert,
dessert,
but we don't have this at home.
We're just going to have this one.
We're on the road.
Right.
You know,
like any other sensible thing,
intake of sensible thing.
Is there a way around it?
I mean,
can you have a bed that's like semi
comfortable?
Was Zero,
zero,
like a medium ground or middle ground?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean I think it all just depends on
how your,
your state,
like I'm looking for really strong cells
had toe,
so like it just comes from the loads
that you expose them to like your,
if you think of like what is the natural
environment for your body,
like you go to a massage therapist like
to push on you and give you pressure.
It's like because your input you are
missing.
Well I get it every night on the ground
so I'm not missing.
I'm not missing all of that movement.
And in helping those tissues become
unstuck because the floor does that for
you for free while you sleep.
Wait a minute.
You think that going and lying on the
ground on the floor is the equivalent to
going and getting like deep tissue
massage?
Um,
well pressure wise it's the same.
It's the same thing.
It's,
it's pressure.
That's what makes sleeping on the floor
so uncomfortable.
I don't have ever gone camping and slept
on the ground and everyone's like
hurting the next day.
Like you don't have the,
you don't have the strength really to do
that.
You don't have the suppleness of the
tissues and so you stiffen and react to
it.
Kind of like if someone pushes on you
really hard,
like too deep at first you tense your
muscles in responsible with with time,
the way how you're probably imagining
sleeping on the ground feels is not how
it feels to me anymore.
It's how it felt to me at the beginning,
but not how it feels to me anymore.
Well,
I've camped a bunch of times,
especially over the last couple years,
have done several times,
five slash six days in a stretch and
sucks.
It's just not comfortable,
but it doesn't feel like deep tissue
massage,
like the difference between massage,
especially sports massage is you're
needing out knots and different scar
tissue and blockages that have happened
from extreme,
from strenuous exercise.
I just don't see how laying on the
ground would do that.
Your jeep,
your massage is targeted and in,
in local to whatever area someone is
applying it.
So in that way the sensations are
different because this is just kind of
whole body all at the same time,
but mechanically speaking it's the same.
It's the same thing,
it's pressure,
it's pressure being applied to tissue,
something pushing on it and moving it
around and it's uncomfortable at first
because it's such a large surface area
of your body.
It's not you being comfortable
everywhere else and then someone working
on,
you know,
three inches or seems like that's like a
mini.
Well,
because it's hard because I mean heart
to hard is not natural either.
Right?
If you're going to sleep,
just imagine what they want.
Something soft.
Yeah.
You always be seeking something
comfortable.
It's just that you,
your bed is so comfortable.
What it does is it doesn't reveal your
discomfort,
so you just assume one position again
the same geometry almost all night long.
So in that way your movement is less
where I moved much more during that
eight hours so that eight hours my cells
have a different experience than someone
who's sleeping in a bed and on a pillow
and.
And when I'm uncomfortable,
I'm,
I changed position,
which is all the time it was at first.
Yeah.
But how long have you been doing this
for?
I've been probably 18 months without a
bed.
Something smaller.
How long did it take to get used to?
It took me like a year to get rid of my
pillow.
It took them a year to get rid of my
Right.
Because it was tight through the neck.
Even though I did,
you know,
all the same neck mobilization and got
massage all of the time.
The bulk of my day was doing the same
thing with how often do you have to turn
your head and look up or look down.
There's no need for actually using the
muscles of your neck anymore.
But finally I was like,
you know,
after doing the stretch I was like,
where?
Why am I doing this stretch?
Like where would this stretch happen?
Naturally it's like,
okay,
well if I was laying on my side curled
up,
you know,
if you look at your dog or your cat
sleeping there.
Thirdly,
doing these weird positions and poses
and then I found the literature on it in
the journal.
It's like,
yeah,
we think that a lot of low back pain is
coming from these repetitive sleeping
positions on,
on beds and here's how all these humans
sleep.
Here's all,
all these other primates and other
animals sleep.
There seems to be some weird way about
the way we sleep,
so I just cleaned up that environment
for myself about a hard mattress.
You could do a hard mattress if you have
a soft one now.
A hard one would give you more pressure.
Yeah,
I mean it's definitely gradual,
you know,
it's not with a pillow.
I took my pillow size and then over a
year just came down to a smaller and
smaller pillow and eventually tee shirt
until I didn't need it.
And with the bed the bed was more
organic because we had little kids and
so it seems like you're never sleeping
in your own bed.
Like everyone's always moving around
beds and I slept in a different
mattress,
like this metric sucks.
And then I was like,
that's ridiculous.
Like it's mattress.
My body should have enough give where,
you know,
a slightly different baby pressure isn't
stressing my body out and then that's
when I just started to explore this kind
of stuff.
A lot of people that are doing this are
sleeping on the ground and having no
couches.
I think furniture free takes awhile.
You don't have to give up your couch
views.
Said how about just sitting on the floor
instead of it,
you know,
it's just with the sitting is the new
smoking stuff.
That's the thing that that research
really showed is that you can be this
like really great exerciser or it was a
new category of sedentary active that,
that all of the active than fittest
people within our culture are still
sedentary.
They're like moving like four percent of
the day.
And since your body again is movement
dependent,
their systems in the fittest,
people are like four percent better than
the people who don't move at all.
So there's like all this space to get
better physically.
And again,
when I say better,
I'm really talking about basic
biological things like procreating,
digesting food.
Some people can't even go to the
bathroom like their guts and their,
their bathroom doesn't work and these
are again basic human functions.
They can't sleep well and like they're
not being like their humanness is
impaired in the same way that you would
see.
Again,
like in zoo animals,
like just pacing and they're not,
they're not on their bio.
Rhythms all messed up,
so I thought,
well I can get myself back on track.
I don't need a couch.
It turned out to be better in all these
other things that we're talking about,
consumerism for our family and space
and,
and I'm having little kids you know and
run around and less to clean and just
less.
It's just less minimal minimalism,
which ends up being maximalism at for
your biology.
Wow.
I'm still tripping out on the fact that
your kids don't get sick.
I'm trying to figure out how that's
possible.
That little immune systems are subject
to so many different little bugs and
stuff when they're hanging out with
other little kids.
I know,
but they just have the strength to push
it right through.
Like it
just.
I think that.
I think that with a lot of illness it's
the delay,
right?
It's like you're making the music as it
sits around for so long,
it just takes like what we envisioned
being sick is,
is the coping mechanism.
It's like a sluggish immune system,
so it's not that my kids don't interact
with it,
but it just happens faster.
I don't know.
I mean we,
again,
we travel all over United States,
Canada and Europe for six weeks.
They dust.
They're very robust.
Kids vaccinated?
No,
not yet.
Not yet.
I'm not an anti vaccine nation.
I just,
again,
I'm a have a particular timeline in a
development that I want them to explore
first and I don't want encroached with
any of that stuff.
And so I maximize lots of other things.
Well,
so like with,
with I'm also an extended breast feeder
so like my children had been breastfed
for like the oldest one.
He stopped when he was three and a half
years.
So a lot of people don't have that going
on.
And then,
you know,
with my younger one,
she's just too.
And so she's still breastfeeding.
So there's lots of other things that I
do.
I'm not really a,
don't do her.
I'm more like here's all the things that
um,
that ended up improving their immune
system.
You know,
they play in dirt,
they've never been exposed to
antibiotics or anti bacterial products,
you know,
things that now are showing up to
accumulate in the system.
And so I think that,
I think that has a lot to do with it.
Do you have any issue or any worry or
concern about your kids catching measles
or mumps or one of these dangerous
diseases that have had a resurgence
because of a lack of vaccinations?
I mean that's,
that's a big issue in the east coast is
the measles and mumps and things along
those lines that used to be kind of
knocked down now because a lot of people
don't want to vaccinate their kids.
You're seeing this make a resurgence.
Yeah.
Well I mean I wear,
like I said,
we're not,
I'm not an anti vaccs like the reason
like you're really vaccinating is for
the benefit of weaker people for the
most part because measles as a whole is
not something that is that dangerous.
I mean there are very few incidences
even when it was really bad that it
would cause death or whatnot.
So there'll be vaccinated at a certain
point for,
for the benefit of the community.
I just am not loading really their
systems with anything.
I'm not particularly worried about
exposure.
They know they don't go to places where
measles,
I mean,
excuse me,
where measles occurs.
Like they're not in doctor's offices.
So they travel all over the world.
Well they travel all over the world.
That's the other thing.
But I mean as,
as far as as I spend time
detecting where like there was a,
there was someone who was exposed to
measles in Washington who came from
Disneyland.
So they.
So I got a notification saying this
person went from Disneyland to the
Seatac airport who then went to this
place,
if you've been at any of these three
places,
which is what our,
you know,
the government put out in local
government.
That was recently,
like in the last week and a half.
No,
this is,
I just got the,
I got it like in the last week and a
half.
So there are,
there are those cases.
Yeah.
So you're not concerned with that.
And it's,
uh,
it's interesting that we have these,
um,
these ideas about what diseases we need
to be gravely concerned about.
Like measles is one,
chicken pox is another belly.
Uh,
all the different ones that people are
terrified of,
the one that kills everybody,
the flu,
the flu fucking kills the shit out of
people.
There's so many people that die every
year,
the flu,
but most people don't get a flu shot.
Yeah.
Shot.
Well,
I just,
again,
from a biological standpoint,
I think we're looking at problems from,
we're all sick in this zoo.
Like we don't see that.
Like you're,
you're,
the way that you are interacting with
the disease has a lot to do with the
state of the being that you're bringing
to the disease.
So I'm working to maximize the state of
the being.
What about nutrition?
Like what kind of nutrition?
Well,
that's the same thing.
So my kids,
like I,
I'm,
I'm much more scared by what other
people feed their family.
I think then I am about diseases that
they'll pick up.
So we don't really eat any processed
food on a regular basis.
Mostly I think for the first couple of
years of their life they had exclusively
proteins and vegetables exclusively.
Yeah.
Like they never had a goldfish cracker,
let me know.
They are swallowing a live fish.
I've been talking about the goldfish
cracker.
They never had a cheerios or goldfish
crackers or any of that kind of stuff.
But um,
yeah,
like we,
I make cookies,
I make desserts.
They have sweets and,
and I'm more lenient now,
but like in that first hunk of time,
you know,
when they're,
when they're developing so much,
but you know,
like they had popsicles,
like they're regular kids you wouldn't
even know because I want them to fit.
I want us all to fit in society.
As weird as my life sounds.
You wouldn't even really know it.
We throw great parties at our house and
every house has just decorated kind of
like Moroccan style.
It just looks like wow.
They have a lot of cool floor pillows or
whatever.
The whole.
It's not just like you walk into a house
going,
where's all the furniture?
This is weird.
It's not like that.
It's just,
it's just slightly,
it's just this kind of our,
our odd are oddness and we are the only
friends in our group that are like this,
you know,
so to them we're kind of frigates like
no one likes the desserts that I make
for kids,
birthday parties or whatever,
but that all being said,
you know,
everyone's kids are like,
they're like,
oh,
there are kids are melting down because
of Xyz.
And I was like,
yeah,
but our kids,
we don't have that.
I mean they have kid meltdowns or
whatever,
but they just,
they just sleep regularly.
They're,
they're healthy,
they're pretty healthy.
Well,
it sounds the sound ridiculously
healthy.
They're healthy.
They've never been sick.
That's,
that's.
I've never heard of anything like that
before.
That's really shocking to me.
I mean,
I thought that that was just like a
natural part of being a child to gets
sick.
Your immune system rebounds and
strengthens.
It is actually good to expose your sick
kids.
I mean,
and we don't,
we don't keep them away from.
We don't keep them away from sick
people.
They just,
if they get sick,
it's just,
it doesn't look like what getting sick
would look like.
I mean,
they're still interacting with any
pathogens and they're responding to it.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
So if they get sick,
it's,
it's a minor thing,
but you wouldn't even the processes and
you don't even know.
Well,
you don't even know that there's,
I mean,
I wouldn't even know that they're sick
because it never,
they never get to an overload points.
What is sick?
Like sick to me is,
you know,
I think um,
my son had,
he just had his second fever and almost
four in four years and there was no
overnight.
Well he just went to bed with a fever
and he woke up.
I think if so,
I.
So for me like sick is like they've been
to the doctor,
they've taken a medication.
Okay.
So what you're saying,
so you think sick is he needs medical
attention?
Yeah.
Or you know how to,
how to stay home from school or had you
know,
something running down out of his nose
or whatever.
Like to me like the,
like the fever,
that fever that he had was like he's
just hot and then it was just gone.
So you slept it up?
Yeah.
Well I don't know.
I guess I guess I compare it to myself.
Like I was at the pediatrician's office
a lot as a kid.
I was,
I remember taking antibiotics once a
quarter,
like a lot.
And do you find yourself sick less as
well?
Yeah,
I mean all of us as a family that's so
unusual.
All my friends that have young children
around my kids' age work,
everyone's battling colds all the time
because your kid's a little petri
dishes.
Yeah.
And that's the same thing.
So I thought,
I just thought the same thing.
Like I compared to our group of families
who all have little kids,
I would say that they're sick a lot and
so I,
you know,
it's like this person is sick,
this person sick,
this person sick.
And we always just go to the party.
It's like whatever.
Because I want my,
I'm not,
I know that they get healthier through
interacting with it,
but I just had my first cold in,
I don't know,
like two years maybe.
And I,
and I've had kids for almost four.
And what is your diet like?
Like what do you eat?
Same thing as a kid.
A lot of fat,
a lot of protein engineered.
That's on purpose.
It's on purpose.
You know,
I,
I try not to.
It turned out to eat a lot of processed
foods and then a lot of like,
we don't do a lot of bread.
You don't need a lot of bread,
but we're not totally green free.
Like I like Amaris,
you know,
like in,
in of like different grains,
Amaranth,
just to a grain or TAF,
which is an Ethiopian grain.
They're just,
they're just freak food.
What is this talk?
What about white bread?
Yeah.
What am I wonder?
Wonder.
No wonder.
No peanut butter and jelly sandwiches in
your house.
We have our version.
I know,
I know.
Good Lord.
It's really weird.
Yeah,
real weird.
Then we take your kids to Disneyland.
They see soda and popcorn and shit like
that.
They freak out.
They,
they freak out about food in packages.
It's like,
it seems to be the packaging more than
anything else.
Like what does that thing with the knob
that they have,
you know,
like the other kids have that and we'll
let them,
you know,
like if we're going,
I'm not going to be like,
no,
you can't have that.
You know,
if someone's handing out something to
everybody,
it's like,
of course you know,
you're,
you're a kid.
This is your community,
this is your time.
But I don't go out of my way to make it,
to put it in there
for them.
I remember when I was a kid,
TV dinners had a very special appeal to
me.
Like there's something about the TV
dinner,
like all of it in that little tray,
like the little potatoes or like molded
to the little tiny little spot where the
potatoes go and the Brownie was baked
right in it.
I remember Barry Steak with the stuff on
the meanwhile,
if you had to eat that now,
he'd be like,
Christ,
what am I putting in my body?
Kenna was so one,
like all those foods.
I look at all the foods and all the
sitcoms that I watched as a TV and it's
constantly,
you know,
as a parent you're going,
am I going too far with this?
A little bit?
Do I want my kids,
you know,
to have,
I really liked my childhood.
My childhood was awesome.
The only thing that I was just playing
with here is biological function because
I think I,
you know,
the difference between our kids and Oz
is that we grew up in a different time.
Like there were no computers.
Like I didn't really sit down in front
of a computer until I was maybe 20.
You know,
I had a typewriter and you know,
I took typing in high school,
but you were running around,
you know,
after school for the most part.
And,
and now you know,
my,
my one year old had my iphone.
I can,
she's a swiping through picking the game
that she wants to play and you're like,
like it's,
she is going to be cast did so much
earlier by,
by this because zero to five is so
important and it's going to be just so
isn't it interesting that,
that it's going to be more than what we
think is going to be.
It's going to affect more than her eyes.
It's going to affect more than,
than her hips,
you know,
it's going to be really how she thinks,
how,
how they,
how they both think is just going to be
so impacted by the age of information.
How did you find this freaky nature
school thing?
Like how did that,
is that the,
is that something that you knew about
before you moved to the location you
live in?
It just,
it just started its first year.
So it's a,
it's a model that they've had in Germany
for a long time.
They've had this kind of for what they
call forest kindergarten for maybe 10
years.
So it's,
it's popular in Europe.
Um,
it just started coming over here.
There's probably,
if you looked online,
you could find,
um,
maybe 100 schools already operating like
this and they're just,
they're just outdoor preschools,
although they're starting to go up
higher,
you know,
where there they're doing the curriculum
does based on child led interests.
You know,
I like my son came home and were just
like taking a hike some time and he was
telling me the names of the trees and
stuff,
like stuff that I didn't even know.
And,
and so it's not,
it's not like doing block,
you're not sitting out in the forest,
you know,
stacking blocks,
you're not coding colors or you're not
doing any.
I think they call them Schema,
like,
like you're not doing any sort of
structured Schema,
but it's,
it happens all very organically.
You just start to notice,
you know,
I think it's definitely lends it self to
a scientific kind of outcome because you
know,
my son's like,
Hey,
look at the frost patterns on this
versus this.
Like,
here's how you can tell,
you know,
where it was frosty and like,
this is clearly underwater.
So they're,
they're just starting to recognize and
observe deed data and details about
things.
So I like that,
you know,
I'm a scientist,
so I like that I see things that way.
So you know,
I don't know if it'll work for both my
kids,
but it definitely works for my son who's
more kinda like
me.
I'm fascinated by the fact that you as a
scientist now,
someone who is an expert in human
movement and biomechanics and all that,
you've decided to try to engineer your
children from the jump.
You know,
I don't know anybody that's done that.
Now it's done it to such a degree that
you've done it where you've gotten rid
of your couch and sit on the floor and
you got your kids in some theory.
Woods school.
They were born at home,
right?
I mean it's born at home.
Oh,
Christ woman.
Now you're going crazy.
What would you do if it was a breach?
If you had to spin the kid around in the
box?
Good midwives can do a lot of stuff,
but it was very,
very close to a hospital.
I know.
Freak you out.
Yeah.
Didn't freak me out.
No.
I have watched and been at lots of
births.
Pelvic pelvic floor mechanics was my
whole undergraduate biomechanics work.
So when you know a lot about something,
there's not a lot of fear there.
Oh,
that makes sense.
There was a healthy dose of of emergency
preparedness to make sure that
everything was going to be okay,
but.
But there was a,
there wasn't a lot of tension or stress
in me because I was.
It was pretty
cool with it.
What about if you need stitches or any
things along those lines?
They can do all that.
Midwife,
midwife.
I didn't do it myself,
but my wife can stitch you up.
Yeah.
Oh Christ.
Some amateur lady down there.
Not An amateur in you with a needle and
thread.
Oh,
Christ.
Knitting needles.
Dirty fingernails and no soap.
Don't know what you soap.
We want to keep everything biological.
No,
it's not like that.
Did you use a tub?
Did you give birth to the kid in the
water one?
Yes.
One.
No.
The water thing is a freaky one.
That's a lot of people that I've known
that have tried to do the birth in
house,
have done it in the tub to think it's
very strange.
Well,
it makes it very comfortable and
supported,
you know,
what your labor and let people get out
though,
you know,
to actually do the birthday climb out of
the tub.
It just,
it's uh,
you know,
there are certain positions.
It's really hard.
You know,
you're,
you're teaching people how to kick and
you're like,
you don't have the hip range of motion
to kick.
Well,
what if you don't have the hip range of
motion to squat these unnecessary
positions that open all the bones up.
Lot of people can't get into them.
Well,
I've always wondered about people that
need to sarian sections,
like women with rain,
narrow hips and you know,
they have a large husband and the baby's
got a giant fucking head.
Like,
oh,
what would you do in the wild?
Like you would die?
No,
I think it's.
I think that again,
there's a lot of things like the growth
rate of the baby that our diet and
movement related.
Again,
that growth rate of the baby,
yes.
Like yes,
like your baby is not this arbitrary
size.
It just pops out like in its DNA are
going to be eight point eight pounds or
whatever.
It's not,
it's not like that.
There is a relationship in gestation
that has to do with that for a while.
They couldn't figure out like what's
the,
what's the signal for a woman?
You start giving birth and they're like,
oh,
it's got to be something to do with the
size of the head and the and the pelvis
and the autism signal and the lungs.
Like they're trying to figure it out.
Like we still don't know a lot of basic
things about how this species worked.
We've kind of gone right down into like
advanced technology and no one's really
done a lot of work just going,
how does this,
how does this species work before we go
over and look at other animals?
Like how does this one work again?
Um,
and so the big thing was like narrow
hips,
like narrow hips is one of my,
is one of my pet peeves,
like telling women that they're too
small to give to give birth,
but then they look at data of women who
are up and move more through their
pregnancy and head circumference,
you know,
that,
that the shape of the baby again is
based on movement of the vessel in which
it's in that,
that it's becoming more understood to be
very mechano regulated.
Mechano meaning like any sort of
mechanical forces on the embryo in the
embryo is sensing movement and there's
pressure on the uterus and,
and,
and that's an environment.
It's an,
a mechanical environment,
affects foot position,
the ability for it to move and twist and
to start that developmental phase.
And there's a lot of things that we do
that limits developing human movement
because we are so still.
So the more active your child is a child
or the more active you are,
rather it changes the shape of your
child in the womb,
the size of your child,
brother in the womb.
We'll allow it affects their spacing.
It affects their space and the pressures
that are on them that are there
mechanical environment
and how does that affect a woman having
narrow hips?
I mean this.
Is it possible that a baby would be
small enough that it would pass through
if she's really.
Whereas if she's sedentary and she has
narrow hips,
the baby's just going to be too big and
fat.
Is that what it is?
Well,
it's not.
I mean narrow hips like your,
your,
your hip,
the obstetrical conjugate this space,
you know,
where the baby is coming out is not a
set structure.
You have hinges in.
There were things articulate and become
bigger or smaller as needed,
but those hinges,
being able to articulate depends on how
fluid you yourself made.
Like how much,
how much movement did you do,
you know,
were you squatting for a long period of
time?
So like squatting is something that's
totally natural for humans and humans
would have to do it a few times a day to
bathroom,
but also getting up and down off of the
floor.
So you imagine what the shape of the
pelvis would be in the mall.
The mobility of the hips and the sacred
and all these joints that play a role in
birth and then you go how but how
natural are they not when you want to
take them to something like birthing
that everyone does.
So I'm a,
I'm a natural birthing advocate,
but at the same time I'm more an
advocate for like if you,
if you want to have like a vaginal
delivery instead of Assyrian,
there's work to do in the same way.
If you want to do a certain kick,
you know,
for your martial arts class that takes
training to reestablish this shape and
mobility so that you don't have too
small of a space.
So what do you do to stretch out your
quote unquote space?
Well you,
you just become more mobile.
So the hips in general,
so like,
like I couldn't well more,
more specifically like furniture,
like again,
look at your relationship with your
furniture.
So you know,
getting pregnant women off the couch and
onto a floor and in,
in,
in what happens when you get on the
floor,
when you get on the floor,
you're essentially doing something that
looks like the exercise that you go to a
class to do for an hour,
right?
So all the things that you do,
if you go to prenatal yoga,
they give you hip opening exercise and
like to sit on the floor.
You can go to the classes too,
but don't go back onto the couch,
which is putting you back into the
position that you're adapting to it.
You don't adapt anymore to your class.
Then you do two sitting on the couch.
You adapt to what you do 100 percent of
the time.
So just sit on the floor in that
position that you're doing
and how has it say on the forum more
beneficial because you're supporting
your weight on a flat structure,
a flat surface.
Well,
you can't physically assume the same
geometry and the couch that you are in
the chair,
right?
So you automatically have to rotate your
hips and drop your knees and your
pelvis.
Now you're engaging,
your core muscles are working,
so the baby's getting bigger,
but you're on the couch,
so even though the baby's getting
bigger,
that weight's never put on the muscles
that hold the baby,
so then you have to start tucking your
pelvis under a,
wearing a baby support belt because
you're not training your muscles
relative to the natural mass
accumulation of having a baby.
You have to be up and moving around with
that weight in order to adapt to it.
You can't put a Kettlebell in your lap,
trained to it,
you to move it and swinging it around.
He had to move and swing around your
pregnancy weight to adapt to it.
And women that have natural or naturally
small hips and they can do all this.
You think it would aid them and they
would have like a normal birth or would
they still have like a huge issue?
I know a lot of women,
like especially in Western medicine,
they get to a point where they're like,
look,
we've got to cut you.
We can't,
that baby's not going to come out.
There's a,
there's a lot of factors that affect,
um,
the birthing process and I don't think
that there is as much evidence for space
being a factor as it is used as a casual
reason to like what I mean if you're at
the point where you've tried to labor
and it's not happening,
you move to a Sicilian that's pretty
normal.
Um,
but the situation in which that Labor
has happened is usually in a city is in
a,
is in a position where the forces aren't
necessarily in your favor.
Right?
Like if you're on your back the whole
entire time,
it's like the baby's not moving down.
It's like,
well,
what could you do to help bring it down?
Like you could be more upright.
You can,
there's so many things you can do,
but they don't necessarily happen well
in a hospital that have their own set of
rules and equipment in which they have
to be monitoring you with.
So a lot of the tradeoff for constant
monitoring and emergency care is the OP.
The optimal process is sometimes
compromised,
too.
Uncomfortable questions the placenta.
Okay.
What do you do with that?
Well with my son,
it went in the ocean with my daughter.
It went into the woods when I was done.
It usually just goes into a bag in the
freezer bag in the freezer,
freeze it until it's.
It's hard.
I mean,
I mean it becomes hard after you put it
in the freezer that why do you put in
the oil?
It's bloody and goopy.
Just.
You can't really throw it in the trash.
I mean it has to,
has to be.
Has to have some place where it can
safely breakdown away from people you
couldn't.
I guess you could say.
Well I mean it's,
it's biomass,
right?
It's right.
But isn't that like food scraps and
that's what it is.
It is just like a.
it's like a takeout bag.
You don't eat it though.
I didn't even know.
Uncomfortable question.
Oh,
is that what the question is now?
Some people do,
some people do.
That's a big thing because you know,
that's what an animal,
a guy.
I'm more of biomechanics,
so like movement in geometry,
like as opposed to like eating my
placenta.
I didn't do that.
Some people boil it down and make a tea
or dehydrated,
make a powder,
scramble it.
Well,
I think that the thought is right.
So most animal mothers eat it.
Yeah,
but the reason is not devoid off
predators because the smell.
Who knows?
That's what you've been told.
Well that's definitely what it is.
With certain animals like deer
biomap,
they don't eat animal protein other than
that,
but.
But because they've been doing it for a
long time,
there can be something that's consumed
in that movement of or that in that
choice of doing so that comes along with
it.
There's a lot of.
In biology there's a lot of naturally
occurring byproduct just because of the
relationship of how something has been
done for a long period of time.
So like I use bees pollinating as an
example.
It's like bees aren't.
They're not actively pollinating,
they're just eating,
but their structure is is pollinating by
default just because it happened to be
the right structure that had some static
electricity because of the way that the
wings flew around and then it happened
and p Harry instead of smooth so that
the pollen could stick in there and then
it just brushes up against it and it
becomes this vessel,
but that's a byproduct of Polynesian is
just something that occurs because of a
structure.
So if you eat something to keep a
Predator from coming,
coming up,
but you've always done it.
Then there can be some sort of compound
that triggers milk production.
Like who knows,
who knows what it's in.
So when you.
When you look at a population of people
who are having kids and it's like wow,
there's a very large percentage of this
population that's struggling just after
having a baby.
Could we be missing some sort of
naturally occurring nutrient?
And I think that's why people take the
placenta is because they're just trying
to hedge their bets.
Like maybe inside the placenta is
something that keeps me from feeling
whatever,
whatever issue like there are diagnosed
with,
you know,
if it plays some sort of role in
hormonal regulation afterwards,
is it part of the input that changes how
your physiology starts going back to
what it was before.
There's so much that we don't know that
things are very easily dismissed as we
know the reason or that's no longer a
necessary structure just because it
doesn't fit into our tank and so you
don't really want to approach biology
and physiology and anatomy with that
heavy bias that the way humans are doing
it right now in La is really an
indication of what humans need to be
doing.
Oh,
people have a natural instinct to suck
on wounds.
Hundred cut your finger.
You naturally do that and then people
would tell you not to do that for the
longest time,
but then they found out the notes alive
as actually very strong healing
properties like we have an instinct to
suck on wounds because it actually does
help.
Yeah.
It's just like that.
It's just part of the part of the
reflexes that we come with that have
kept us alive for so long.
Uncomfortable.
Question number two,
do you guys have toilets?
We do regular old toilets platforms
around platforms around.
There were regular toilets.
Yeah.
And the squad platform.
What do you build that?
Well,
you can build it,
buy it,
and is bought a squatty potty and you
just throw it up and
you don't make loud noises when someone
drops.
No doesn't because the height,
you mean your butts at the same
altitude.
You can.
You can actually just still sit on the
toilet and just put your feet up.
So your hips and knees are just a
different angle.
You don't even have to work any muscles
differently.
Don't actually have a squatty potty.
Can do that.
Any person sit down and you put your
feet up.
Just take like if you have a stack of
books or if you have like a wastepaper
basket is flip it over and put your feet
up on it.
Just get your hips and your knees to a
different,
um,
joint angle because it turns out again
that the tubes of,
of elimination line up better when you
do the other,
that it's part of the system and without
that then you have to start bearing down
and adding forces into the system that
aren't so good for.
They're good to accomplish that task,
but they're not good for maybe the whole
structure like that.
All that intra abdominal pressure over
time,
if that's how you're forcing it to get
out moves things and other ways.
Like when you have to poop in the woods,
it comes out real quick.
Whereas like if you're sitting down a
toilet,
it's like sometimes you can read a book
or go answer a few tweets.
It takes awhile because you have to work
against the technology of a toilet.
That's interesting.
How did we get into the toilets then?
What?
Where did that come along?
Women from toilet.
That was just uncomfortable.
Question number two,
how did we as human beings,
how did we get to this,
this throne that you sit down on?
How come nobody figured out that a long
time ago?
Well,
I think that with civilization,
part of another inherent component of
civilization that you have to be better
than someone else,
you know,
and so a lot of the things that we do,
um,
our,
our ways of delineating ourselves from
sap,
what we would call savages are more
primitive people like your shoes.
You didn't want your skin to be too dark
or Tan,
you know,
you wanted to show that you had more
affluence that you weren't as barbaric.
You didn't have to poop on it,
you could just poop it and push it flush
or,
and it went away.
And like it just,
it just comes soft hands,
cultured demeanor.
You were less animal if you were less
animal.
Correct.
You're trying to be more animal.
Uh,
but the word is primitive.
I am a primate.
Yeah.
What advancements the society make that
you think has society made that you
think are beneficial?
Well,
gosh man,
I think medicine is benefit.
I mean,
I think everything is beneficial.
It's just that what I'm more concerned
about is what's,
what has been,
what is no longer needed that is still
essential.
So it's,
it's,
I don't,
I don't have really an aversion against
civilization and technology.
It's just that vitamin C is still
necessary,
like we can't get around the fact that
vitamin C is still necessary.
So I'm just trying to figure out
diseases.
So when you're trying to figure out
diseases you have to kind of boil down
to could this be a rising because of
some not and input some essential input
that we're not getting.
And so as people get more and more
advanced than our,
our health again in the terms of
biological sense isn't getting better
with us.
And so what happens to a species that
advances itself right out of being a
species,
you know,
like that.
That's more what I'm,
I'm interested in.
So I like it all.
I like all technology.
Netflix,
Netflix might be my favorite technology.
It just seems to me that you,
you're,
you're in this really weird state of,
of sort of primitive re-engineering.
I don't want to like,
uh,
our primate re-engineering.
I mean,
that's,
that seems like what you're doing,
like you're,
you're looking at all the various
various components of society that you
feel like are non beneficial.
You're eliminating them and you're,
you're doing it from the jump with your
children.
I find that very fascinating.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean it's a bed,
like the things sound radical,
but again,
as far as humans on the planet right
now,
they're really not so they might be
more,
they might be more radical because are
decidedly non American,
but I don't think I'm really going out
of my way that much to be more animal.
Like it's just like I don't feel my life
is enhanced with a bed.
I don't think my life is enhanced with
like I'm obviously letting go the things
that I can't live without.
There are certain things that,
that I know I still have a car.
I some weird thing that you said in your
car and you sit on a lot.
I just want to sit as little as possible
in it.
I try to walk as many places as I can
sit in a weird way or anything I'll sit
across.
I mean,
I'll sit in as many different ways in
the car as long as I hit the gas and the
pedal with your left foot.
No,
no,
I don't play around with that kind of
stuff.
Now that can be dangerous.
Right?
That'd be weird.
Like sensory input is huge.
You're driving,
you're using a lot of motor memory when
you're driving.
I don't know if I would start playing
around with that kind of stuff.
Yeah.
I've used my left foot to break
sometimes and it's amazing how dumb my
left foot is like my right foot is.
Ooh.
It's so like,
it's interesting that we figured out a
way to use the foot for input,
you know,
and the other thing you find out is that
your left foot gets tired if you were to
try to drive the gas.
We left,
but like I hurt my right knee once and I
was driving with my left foot.
Your left foot gets tired.
It gets tired.
Just pressing down on the gas pedal.
It's makes you think like what?
What muscles are being programmed by my
right foot that are not being programmed
by my left.
Like there's a lot of things that I do
really good with my right side.
I don't do so good with my left side.
Yeah,
it's weird.
So yeah,
hold the bag.
That's a big one.
Throw kicks is another one that certain
kicks I just don't do as well with my
left side.
And the.
It's just.
I wonder now,
especially after talking to you like
what other chains of things are not
working as well because of that in
balance.
Yeah.
Well I think for me that brings up that
notion of alignment is an alignment is
when you're moving,
you know,
alignment in your,
in your car is like when you're,
when the relationship of all of the
parts are where they should be,
and then the way that you drive
optimizes the longevity of the structure
of the car as a whole.
Like you don't like,
you don't have anyone.
We'll getting its job done as a wheel is
wearing down the break on that side
where it's costing you something that it
shouldn't.
So it's the same thing with the body,
you're trying to figure out your
alignment,
which is how can I be using my arm
without
wearing down my shoulder prematurely
because the muscles between the two are
tighter than they should be because I
always do the same thing with my left
arm.
So I think it's less about.
I mean muscle balancing is one way to
look at it,
but also just look at what are the
movements you do in your life.
Like if you had to make a list of the
top 10 moves you do in your life outside
of your exercise program,
like what are they?
It's sitting from like getting up and
down out of chairs is a thing that you
do most often,
but we don't do very much with our body
at all.
When it's not exercising almost nothing.
What kind of exercise do you do?
No,
none.
None really in that I have really
eliminated structured exercise time out
of my life,
but if you plotted my body on a graph,
what you would see is probably five
miles of walking a day almost carrying
something.
Almost always while doing that,
but you know,
it's in different arms all of the time.
I'm working,
you know,
working on the house.
My stillness is on the computer time,
but really it's just that getting up and
down off of the floor,
sitting on the floor in different ways,
which would,
which would look like stretching I would
say to most people.
Right.
So I'm always working on some sort of
stretch,
but it's really just to get something
accomplished.
So no lifting weights,
no squatting,
no.
Well I circled lifts,
squat because I don't have furniture,
so I probably do 200 squats a day,
but I don't do them repetitively.
They're distributed throughout the day
and they're held sometimes for three or
four minutes while I'm doing something.
So I would say that my moves,
if you,
if you loaded up my moves and put them
in,
it wouldn't look that much different
than a workout probably.
It would probably look most like,
like a cross,
like a crossfit kind of workout,
you know?
Um,
as far as you know,
the variation of moves and my kids are
heavy.
So like you're them around and moving
them around,
but it would,
it would just,
it just looked like regular living,
never exhausted and never breathing
heavy.
You never had a rapid heart rate.
So your cardiovascular improvement from
something like that is probably pretty
minimal,
right?
Well,
I mean,
but I also go out like.
So we're actually going out and hiking.
So if you go out and hike a couple miles
again,
carrying or hurting kids like it does
stay.
Yeah.
You do.
Like your heart rate is elevated.
I still practice recovery.
You know,
again,
one of the reasons you do cardio,
you do cardio because this idea that you
want to keep your heart strong enough to
do what it's supposed to be,
to distribute oxygen.
Your cardiovascular system distributes
oxygen,
but just because it's beating faster,
working harder is not accomplishing
whole body oxygen distribution.
In fact,
it's pulling blood away from anything,
not doing that thing that you're doing
in the moment.
So even that idea of cardio comes from
being still all the time.
What can I consume in a short period of
time that keeps my heart muscles strong
instead of going,
how can I take the resistance away from
my heart and distribute my oxygen all
the time,
like my cardiovascular system is working
all the time because I'm moving all the
time.
I think what we're talking about,
two different things.
I'm talking about like what you're
trying to accomplish,
whether or not you're trying to push
your body to an optimum state,
have you look into optimize your body's
performance.
You really not going to get that just by
caring kids doing,
you know,
sitting down on the ground like your,
your body,
like the difference between exercise.
A lot of people are thinking of exercise
as being something where,
uh,
I guess you're just trying to lose a
little weight or stay active or sweat a
little bit.
What I'm talking about is optimizing
your physical body,
like strengthening your body,
strengthening your cardiovascular
system,
strengthening your physical structure.
Like A,
I'm a big believer in especially
resistance exercises.
I think that it's very important for
bone density.
It's very important to resist the aging
process and muscles.
Keeping muscle density,
keeping bone density like you're not
doing anything like that.
Well,
again,
I think it's about how you're using the
word optimization optimization.
To me,
if you're optimizing the fitness
performance tests like one rep Max or or
a strength goal,
whether it's a static or physics perform
like a physical performance,
like how much weight can I move with his
body part and can I get more and more?
That's fine as long as your body is also
being successful at getting biological
tasks done and I think that in a lot of
cases people can have very high levels
of this fitness optimization for
performance for athletic performance,
but not be performing hundred percent
biologically
speaking.
How so?
Well,
I think of like.
I think if like I in the book I use
cycling as an example where you can have
people who have huge vo,
two Max capacity because they're
training,
they're doing a ton of endurance
but the bone density in their hips and
most competitive cyclists is lower than
what it should be like.
They actually have like the hips have of
a 70 year old woman with osteoporosis
because they're not carrying any weight
because they've.
They've isolated the variable that
they're training for.
Bone density is not necessary,
but it's a waste actually have bone
density,
so there's a lot of health tradeoffs
that occur when we train for performance
without keeping our eye constantly on
biology.
So I would say that my bone and see the
bone density of,
of hunter gatherer populations is way
higher than it is in even like heavy
lifters because bone density is a whole
head to toe phenomenon and and you know
like people who have warned sues their
entire time,
like the bone density and their feet is
pretty low.
Like the size and shape of your bones is
small already.
Even if you do a lot with it,
that,
that the size and the shape is,
is,
is limited by the fact that you don't
move all the time.
Even though you do a ton of work to
optimize your fitness level in that
hour,
you're sedentary 96 percent of the time
so that the physical cap optimization,
it's just different.
It's just different.
It's just a different set of variables
by which to assess yourself,
but they're not mutually exclusive or
not.
Someone could be doing everything that
you're doing and also lift weights and
improve their guns,
but I think you can be too strong.
Like I think that some of you can be too
tight,
so get in the birthing community.
There's this,
there's this thing of,
you know,
why are women who I'm doing a lot of
exercise,
their muscles get to the point where the
tension,
the resting tension is higher than what
it should be like saying their pelvic
floor and then they're having to
generate way more force or their tissues
will tear or give because the tension is
greater than what is natural because you
can.
Because you can get stronger and
stronger and stronger.
But at what point is your attention
higher than natural?
Because of the context of doing nothing
else.
The rest of the time,
like I will carry our kids,
but then there's like huge,
like very fit guy and he came up to us
like if I had to carry my kids,
there's no way.
My back had tolerated it for more than
20 minutes and I've been following you
guys around all day and you've had these
kids for hours.
He's like,
I can't.
I couldn't even do it.
So who's stronger?
No terrorists.
Kids for 20 minutes.
That's ridiculous.
It was back.
I mean he was,
he was,
he worked out a lot,
but he obviously had some sort of weak
leak in a system like and of course you
can mitigate
that right by better training practices,
but the thing is a bad example because I
think anyone can overload their system
and an unnatural way and then that's a
huge issue with weightlifting,
especially with people do isolation
exercises.
I'm a big proponent of functional
strength exercises like full body weight
x or full body movements and things
along those lines and that's something
that for a long time people just weren't
even aware of this,
this,
this sort of crossfit type Olympic body
lift body weight or Olympic lifting
style,
a full body exercise thing.
That's like fairly recent as far as
trends.
For the longest time everybody was doing
like preacher curls,
which are just ridiculous,
you know?
Yeah,
there was,
it's,
it has come in the last 10 years to a
whole different level of functional,
so I think I'm just calling for it to
become even more functional,
like real functional,
like stuff that you would actually do in
life.
Yeah,
I mean I'm,
I'm fascinated by your approach,
but I just wonder how Ab,
how practical it would be for the
average person.
You seem to have engineered your life in
order to do it this way and it's great.
It's wonderful,
but I just wonder how many other people
could sort of apply that to their lives
unless they had some sort of a mean.
You have to have a lot of freedom to do
what you're doing,
you know,
what does your husband do?
Do you have a job that works with you?
We've just run our company from online,
you know,
it's,
I have a podcast and the blog and write
books and stuff.
As your podcast Katie says,
Katie says,
so just talks about this kind of stuff.
Breaking it down though and in,
in much smaller bites.
So yeah,
we were very fortunate.
We worked hard to get to this point
though,
were just managing me and and what I,
what I produce and speaking do lesbian.
So he's like sort of like a manager or a
coworker with you and sort of helps you
along with what you're doing?
Yeah,
we're both also raising the kids.
Right.
So we're like,
we're sharing so there's just like,
you're just constantly jumping in and
tagging in,
tagging out and in taking turns working
at night and someone works at early in
the morning and just getting all the
things done that need to.
He used to do.
He used you guys became the grizzly
Adams family.
He was an editor,
like a,
like a magazine article editor sees a
copy editor and a lot of just kind of a
jack of all trades just writing.
So it's helped me out.
Producing,
writing,
yes.
Oh,
I bet that sitting down writing all
this,
he's probably really aware of what
you're talking about and the issues that
people that do that kind of thing face I
was probably attractive to him to sort
of pursue what you're advocating.
Yeah.
What,
and it's funny because he was actually,
he was total a barefoot guy,
you know,
just now I didn't know this about him
when he was in college here in La.
He's Kinda,
he's Kinda like the big Lebowski.
My husband is very similar to if you
know who the character of the big
Lebowski is,
he's Kinda like,
it's Kinda like that guys,
like the dude is just kind of a cool
kind of hang out Kinda guy.
And,
and he was barefoot like in a bathrobe a
lot of the time.
So he was already had this barefoot
component and then he worked in New York
City,
you know,
barefoot in a bathrobe.
I think a lot of the time getting an
ingredients for his white Russians.
Like the big Lebowski,
like the dude from big Lebowski rights
is the dude.
He's like the dude.
He's a stoner then.
Yeah.
That's a good place for you to be the
Pacific northwest.
It's a good place for stoners.
It's right here.
It's everywhere up there.
It's grown wild Washington man.
Yeah.
Well,
Washington is one of the few states that
had the courage to make it legal sounds
Oregon now and some couple other places
is going to become legal too.
Um,
I think what you're doing is really
fascinating.
I,
like I said,
I just wonder how many people could
actually apply it to their life,
but I think it's really cool that you're
doing it.
I think it's really cool that you're a
sort of documenting it and explain it.
And do you talk about this kind of stuff
a lot?
And Katie says,
I do.
People have questions.
I think their questions are like,
how do I,
how do I do it?
You know,
some people tweet me their pictures of
like here's,
here's me sitting on the floor in front
of my couch.
You know,
the couch is still there,
but they're just sitting on the floor
and fun of it.
Or we have indoor monkey bars,
so they're.
So that even if we're inside,
you know,
the kids can still train,
we can all train.
So they just kind of go down the
kitchen.
Yeah,
you guys are freaks.
But.
So are lots of other people now.
Yeah.
Listen,
people come over my house.
I think I'm a freak too.
I mean,
we're all freaks in our own little weird
way.
Sure.
But I think you were.
Freakiness is a very healthy and I'm
conscientious freakiness and they'd say
it's pretty.
Obviously you're thinking this is not
just something,
you're just jumping into this.
You put a great deal of thought into
this.
Yeah.
Um,
what kind of criticisms do you get?
I mean,
I'm sure you must get criticisms because
the anti anti anti-vaccine.
Well,
none.
Not even your anti-vaccination yeah.
The fact that you have not yet
vaccinated your kids.
Well,
I don't know.
It's the first time I ever told anyone
publicly than I don't.
Yeah.
No one's ever asked me before.
I'm not anti.
I'm not an anti.
I'm not an anti vaccinator.
I believe in,
in vaccines.
I just,
I've just,
there's,
there's just a timeline like I am.
I at what I didn't do as do early,
you know,
vaccines.
I have a lot of.
I work with a lot of people in medicine,
a lot of people on a regular basis.
And so I just have the way that I'm
doing it,
but um,
yeah,
I guess it is a big,
that's a hot topic.
It is a hot topic.
It's a hot topic in terms of criticism
as well.
People love to jump on people that
aren't vaccinating their kids or jump
in.
Anyone who's trying to connect any
vaccinations towards any sort of
ailments and diseases.
And you know,
I,
I've talked to many doctors and that are
pro vaccine that think that the
protocols that we instill as far as like
everyone being subscribed to the same,
like this is probably not the best way
to deal with anything biological because
people have so much bio diversity.
There's so much difference between one
thing that will make someone terribly
ill and the same exact substance,
one effect someone at all,
whether it's allergies or sensitivities
to certain medications.
And it's just you're going to run the
risk,
especially when you're,
you're introducing a lot of chemicals
into a very young immune system.
A very young child.
Yeah,
I mean I,
I,
I would agree there's a,
there's a timing.
There was a timing issue for us in the
way that we wanted to do it.
Um,
I don't think.
I'm not really even a,
I don't really believe that the
vaccinations are tied to any ailment or
anything.
Like that's not,
that's not my bag at all.
It's just more like there is like,
I think it's a load I think of just a
load to the body as a whole and watching
I'm wanting my children to process and
develop certain things first where you
know,
the risk of,
of any overload or mismatch as you call
it.
Like in terms of biology and medicine
where it's just less of a less of a new
new thing,
you know,
the structure is a little bit more,
more formed and more able to process
anything that you put into it.
It seems like there's an issue with,
um,
some parents where some parents want to
criticize people that are raising their
kids in a different way and they do it
for either because they don't like the
way it makes them examined,
the way they're raising their kids.
So they get,
they do it defensively or they're
judgmental or you know that everybody
thinks they're doing it the right way
and then everybody else is doing it the
wrong way.
Do you face a lot of that?
Because this is a very unconventional
way of raising children?
It is.
And that's I think out of all the.
If I got any criticisms it would be for,
for that,
for the way that we want to raise our
kids and I,
and I don't have any problem with the
way that anyone wants to raise her kids.
Like this is just what we're,
this is just what we're doing and this
is what we're trying.
I just happened to be in a more public
format and I'm writing about it.
I mean I'm,
I'm making.
There's very conscious biomechanical
choices of why I'm doing what I'm doing.
Like I got to go,
here's the process of
mechanotransduction and here's the list
of diseases and here's,
here's the known environments.
And so here's the environments that
we're changing.
So in that way it's kind of like a,
an experiment in,
in current process,
right?
That we're,
that we're doing.
But yeah,
it's,
I think the worst thing I was ever
called by someone,
you know,
in a comment section and I don't spend.
I spent almost zero time reading
comments or whatever.
It's not my sound.
My thing is smart.
Yeah.
I was just like,
I feel like the quality of interaction
isn't someone who is really wanting to
have a thoughtful discussion with me to.
Unless you really.
I mean it's,
it's hard to manage those things too if
you can.
No one wants censorship,
but you've got to eliminate assholes.
You know?
It's not like censorship as far as the
way the ideas are expressed or the ideas
themselves.
It's the way they're expressed in the
insulting manner in which people can do
it anonymously.
If there was some reason to not.
If there's some way to not have it be
anonymous and that you would see,
then all of a sudden you're interacting
with some person and what's lacking is a
social cue.
So there's things that people will tell
you things in online that they would
never tell you,
just looking at you in front of you.
And if they did,
they would be completely socially
retarded to do that.
But just it's,
there's no consequences.
Just typing something shitty.
And the one thing that you can glean
that you can get from that is that all
those people were socially retarded.
Anyone who does that like,
okay,
you're input is,
it's not valid because your input like
this insulting thing that you've
written,
you've written that because you're an
idiot.
Like that's it.
That's the only reason why you do it.
If you're a sensitive person or if
you're a person that considers that
person,
the other analyst I person,
obviously he's doing something horribly
racist or sexist or whatever,
you know,
whatever.
In some way that victimizes other
people,
you're just talking about someone's
opinions and ideas and doing so in a
very insulting way.
You're doing so because you're an
emotionally stunted fuckhead.
I'm like,
that's what you are.
And so that's why you're.
That's why you're drawn to this
anonymous contribution in the first
place.
Whereas the ver,
the large majority of people and they
watch a youtube video will not leave a
comment,
right?
The large majority and the people that
do the overwhelming number of negative
comments like it's represents way more
than I think the average population
because you're dealing with a sort of a
stunted group in the first place.
I think you're already.
There's already a certain type of person
who will comment so you're not looking
at.
You're not looking at a good cross
section of humanity.
I don't think when you're looking at
youtube comments like I have a message
board and it's,
it's amazing that mean had,
I've had it since 1998 and that there's
always going to be assholes.
There's a certain amount of assholes,
so you just going to get a certain
amount.
People,
they just want attention so they just
want to be shitty and insulting.
But the intelligent discussions that the
large majority have intelligent
discussions and an interesting different
viewpoints.
And once people get away from this idea
of just a demanding attention by just
being just shitty,
which is what a lot of people do in
these social network forums,
whether it's twitter or facebook,
they get more attention by being shitty.
Uh,
but once you get past that,
like you can find communities,
you can cultivate communities,
but it's hard to do without some form of
regulation when you regulate your
sensor.
And so it becomes like,
you know,
what's going on in France right now,
of course,
right with the,
this,
uh,
cartoonists,
these people that were killed,
well now Francis arrested like 60 people
for making facebook posts that they
thought were either in,
in support of terrorism or criticizing
their government.
They re arrested a comedian recently for
some,
some comment that he's made about the
relationship between terrorism and this,
this,
this horrible tragedy.
It's really kind of fucked up because
it's like,
it's Kinda counterintuitive to the whole
idea that you're supposed to be
supporting in the first place.
But the,
the communities that we have online
right now,
I think a big part of it is they don't
feel the interaction.
They just send it out there,
almost like a message in the bottle.
And you were on the other hand
receiving.
Do you read all your,
a lot of your comments on your board
still?
I read a lot of the comments on the
board.
I read a lot of comments on twitter.
I still interact with people,
but it's like I.
I believe it's like snake venom like you
get if you just get bitten by a snake
and never been bitten before,
you kind of fucked.
But if you get snake venom all the time,
you go,
oh,
I know what that is.
Some fucking Weirdo.
That's a good way to say it.
You could feel the.
I know I have a very kind kind of group
of people who read and follow him.
Tweet at.
Very rarely do I get,
you know,
the kind of person,
but you occasionally get mean people.
I mean the biggest one was someone who
said that I was racist.
I was raising my children is
colonialists and because I didn't have
furniture,
Linda,
you don't even want to sit down.
You sit in your own culture,
furniture and stuff like sit in your own
cultures,
furniture,
plantation furniture.
It was such a random irritation for this
person,
so can't read that.
No.
Katy Bowman,
you're awesome.
I really enjoyed this conversation.
There's a lot of fun.
Thank you.
Very educational.
I learned a lot from this.
I'm going to have to think about a lot
of things you said.
I'm going to have to really go over it
and I'm going to listen to your podcast
too.
Um,
so it's.
Katie says it's available everywhere.
Our tunes.
The whole deal.
Yes.
And your books people can get them.
Bookstore,
Amazon,
and your website.
Katie says.com.
[inaudible] DOT com.
Thank you very much for doing this.
I really appreciate it.
It was a lot of fun by everybody.
Big Kiss for.
Okay,
cool stuff.
Yeah,
it was a lot of fun.
Yeah.
I guess you don't know who.